Uh yeah. Well, he he occupies a space I guess with a bunch of
people who have been friends for like a decade, right? Like all
the other people who kind of operate around him have been friends
for a long time. So to anyone that you know to all the to all
to Queen Jtore, all the that are going to fun the next stream
off the back of this little rant. Okay. Anyone that doesn't like
me. Okay. I can't remember what I was going to say now. I can't
say I thought too much about all the people that are going to
be watching this later. But it feels like Tommy wanted me to
like intervene in some way. Like, you know, as if as if a Queenman
is some sort of bastard extension of my body, my fleshy mass.
Queen's little faces in my chest that Oh, I'm going to hate people.
I'm selfhating. It's like those hands in like a vacuum. So, I'm
so
sorry. I'm like I This is actually hilarious. Hold on.
Tommy's on to something. There's definitely something there.
This is uh Willie Mack show responding to Tommy C's video where
he accuses Chudlo Logic of being a snake tries to over like Nicholas
Dario and Willie Mack and all these other dude what the what
is happening? Why are these people making this? Dude, Chud was
so nice today. Chud was so nice and these people are losing their
minds. What did Chad do? How did Chad react to everything? Did
you see the Did you see the Tommy C video that we watched last
night? Yeah, I saw some of the stream last night.
Okay. Okay. We got to do a quick thing. I I'm guessing Quimman
just joined because he's the person who sent me this. Huge things
happening. Queen is Can you make me skinny again? I don't want
to be fat next to He's so skinny next to me. Make me skinny.
Oh, yeah. Sure. Sure. Hold on. Hold on. I need to fix this as
well cuz you guys are on different things. We'll do this for
a second and then Good. Okay. Feeling
Yeah. Yeah, it's fine. Um, hold on. Let me I'm doing some stuff.
So, you got to Queen, you want to talk for two seconds?
Let me see. Can you summarize Chud's reaction to it? Summarize
Chud's reaction. Um, yeah. From Yeah, summarize. You thought
You think Chud made a, you know, good call not going hard on
Tommy C and on everybody else today? I think it's very diplomatic.
Yeah. What do you think of diplomacy,
Um, I it doesn't seem to be working. That's what I think of it
here. I what I don't understand. Okay. To me, this is why it
doesn't make any sense to me. Hold on now. Let me switch this
and I think it'll be good. Yeah, there we go. Okay, perfect.
Everybody's getting their outfit on. To me, I sit here and I'm
like, dude, Chud did the hard thing and like clearly you guys
talked to Tommy C. cuz Tommy C did not watch that content on
his own, right? Clearly you guys talked to Tommy C. He's like
kind of just reporting your feelings. And Chud went, "You know
what? I don't care. I understand that you could be upset. I'm
not going to like make a big deal out of it at all." And he like
basically says like, "Yeah, I'm not going to. It's fine. Whatever.
We'll talk offline and it'll be fine." And then Willie goes and
does this. That was funny. Where's my There it is. Perfect.
I think there was like a moment on the stream last night where
I don't know what it was. Quan said that you are setting a narrative
about Chud
that he's um like bending the knee to Yeah. to Dior or something.
Kissing the ring. Kissing the ring. Oh, kissing the ring. Okay.
Is that what happened this morning as well?
No. I mean, kind of
like he did
say Tommy C was losing his mind, but it it's um
he was just nice and uh just said, you know, we should have a
conversation about it in public or in private,
but do that.
Hold on. I need to go ahead and pull my own logs here. Cuz I
I basically said, "How do you even handle this if you're Chud?"
I think I gave like a characterization of the exact way I had
handled it. And uh I think this is pretty much it. I think this
is uh he must have been looking looking for how you just call
Tommy.
Okay, call Tommy. Nick and I are fine. One comment wouldn't blow
up our professional relationship. I think Tommy's just asked
mad about Queen is trying to get Nick and I to fight because
of his jealousy/sility. Yeah, I think that's like the essence
of what Chud said by the way, more or less I think.
Is it almost true? It It does sound like it's a reasonable response,
but the way that you guys are talking about it seems as if uh
Tommy's not as mad that he's going off of like gossip behind
the scenes to him, right? Yeah, there's a bit of that for sure.
It's both. But yeah, there's a he's he's missing that it's missing
out that part where obviously everyone's uh just seething behind
the scenes, I guess, and refuses to talk about it in public cuz
uh I don't know it look bad or something. I'm not sure. They
won't if they think there's legitimate criticism, they won't
even bring it up that it's a problem, right? I don't even know
who Tommy C is, but I've known that Quimman hated him for like
before I knew who this guy was. That's what I said. So how long
has it been Quean?
Um, like a year. Okay. 11 months. A year maybe. I didn't like
him before that to be to be clear. I remember watching a podcast
he was on when I was like um when was baited? What year was Baited
Podcast? That must have been I was probably like 16 or something
and he was annoying. I remembered him from back then. But in
any case, I don't know why I don't know why Willie would hype
this. Oh, sorry, not this. Although this is also hilarious.
Dude, the posts are so funny, man. It's actually so cool this
is happening.
I love that Chun specifically was like this is the one outcome,
the commentary civil war thing. That's the one outcome I don't
want and like that's the outcome everybody else is pushing it
towards for like it's just like he's just like this would really
be really stupid guys. We literally have fun. These people are
literally is Hassan's Okay, the the thing I'm mad about here
is the the sentence Hassan's haters are weaponizing the ADL to
take him down.
Even if you're
anti-Han, you have to recognize that that's true. How is that
the tweet at the center of the screen? The tweet at the center
of the screen. This person has explicitly said they're contacting
the ADL. They're talking to the ADL. They are a Hassan hater.
Where part of this statement is false? This is true. Shamu just
made a totally incontrovertably true point here. Uh it's just
like inarguable. No no point disagreeing with this. Even if you
hate a song, obviously true. And then everyone in the there was
like another reply. One minute I put it in spite to you. I'll
send to you now. Um yeah, there's obviously that one that says
it makes sense that Hassan and gropers like Queen and J Stalker
and Shimu would support each other since they all hate with a
burning passion. There's also this one.
The stardust. Oh, son's hater weaponizers are weaponizing on.
He just got a jQ on Maine. Is that what we're Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god. Oh wow.
Good lord, dude. I don't I This is seriously just No, don't wait.
Have you ever seen the Stardust clip? I don't think she's seen
the Stardust clip. Oh my god. Let me grab this one second. This
is so funny. I might be able to just go and pull it up. The star.
She's changed Twitter right now. We'll just link to it. Yeah,
that should still
Yeah, it goes off the number anyway.
So, this is this is the clip, Jerry.
Someone posted this clip elsewhere. I downloaded this so you
can watch me buffer in real time. So, somebody posted this clip
to mock Stardust for this. And I, by the way, Stardust, when
I got banned, she was like actually trying to help me. I don't
really have a problem with Stardust. Unfortunately, I'm also
friends with Queen, so probably we're just never going to be
friends. Really, Stardust? Sorry. Sorry. But I will always give
you a shout out for being like super helpful, super cool.
Something I would help back. Yeah, he will never be your friend
or some of the that she said after what happened to me.
Yeah, sure.
Well, actually, I don't know, but yeah, I don't know. She says
she doesn't feel bad for me, which basically just I don't know.
You can't be friends with me. Um, you being in the Idubbbz video
is what's going to cause this harassment, but in reality, it's
you, Ethan. You're acting like you haven't spent the last year
and a half doing everything in your power to push people to bully
and harass me, including weaponizing propaganda organizations
such as the ADL to get me banned off Twitch because I made a
joke about you not being weaponizing propaganda organizations
such as the
Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow.
Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. What's happening? Wow. Wow. Oh. Oh my god. What
dude? WTF?
Oh my god.
Omg. Oh my god. Omg.
I lose my mind. What is going on? Are we just jQuing on Maine
now? What's going on? Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my
god. Omg.
It's jQuing to accuse Ethan of weaponizing the ADL. It's It's
jQuing.
Is that the little Timmy thing?
No, that's not the It's the little Timmy thing. But it's the
little Timmy thing. But
oh, the JQ is uh suggesting control the world, control media,
control the US through money, shadowy influence. Yeah. The question,
right?
Yeah. Yeah, that's the JQ. Sorry, I thought you were asking about
the ADL and I was like, the ADL basically did the little Timmy
thing but for juice. That was what I meant.
Oh. Um,
I actually super don't understand this.
You don't understand? Okay. So, basically the ADL is a it's the
Anti-Defamation League. It is a a organization that was I know
what that is. I know what that is. I know what that is. Is it
Are you Are you being anti-semitic by saying that people are
trying to use the ADL to take out Hassan? That's what is claiming.
Yeah. argument they make is that the only reason people accuse
Ethan of coordinating with the ADL is because he himself is but
in reality um he has coordinated with Dan Saltman who has coordinated
directly with the ADL and yeah but realistically like
but Dan Sman literally coordinates with the ADL because he's
he's like I'm so they're going to care what I have to say I'm
going to talk to and get it handled quite literally true like
literally I I think that
I didn't think about that. Yes. I think that's actually he was
he's quite literally like Yeah. Uh we're going to do the anti-semitism
thing cuz that never loses. Unironically, I think that's the
play that he did. Yep.
So, unfortunate that Yeah. Thank you. Just like he did the the
the woman thing with forethought. It's just like just reach for
whatever the most powerful oppressed group that you can find
in the situation. My daughter has to grow up in a world with
somebody like you proceeds to podcast with Destiny for
sorry it's just it's just a good time every time you think about
it. Quimman here is an uncle in the ADL. Careful guys that might
actually be anti-semitism but that's
okay. What believes in the exposure therapy? Okay. He believes
in it. True. Um, that was one thing I didn't realize we're actually
going to spend. We We've been reading legal documents a lot of
today. One thing I was going to possibly get to is some of the
Papa Gut stuff today just to see how that was going. We can do
pop gut tomorrow. I got dumb. What the else is happening?
Yeah. Well, apparently LA might be getting burned down. Is there
more LA stuff? No. No. After dark it was all dead. It was like
unfortunate.
No. Hassan would not have joined them after dark. Hassan might
go tomorrow if it's martial law still. Oh, right. That's what
you said. You said tomorrow. Yeah, I am. You said tomorrow.
Tomorrow. Um.
H. Yeah. Why did I don't understand? This was on Is this on Tommy's
video? The Willie M comment. Not that one.
I don't have it up anymore. The am I doing this one? 33 minutes
ago. Do we get Did we get uh Chud's comment on this, by the way?
How his how how's your deescalation going?
I should I shouldn't be an [__] cuz I am literally
like when I speak on stream or when I like put those messages
spot I'm literally like mostly when I'm seriously me making a
message advocating deescalation. There's probably a dick move
of me to also make fun of him for the deescalation failing. Um
but he's funny also Chud Logic is probably being the most um
mature adult person. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
But he knows where he is, right? Uh yeah. Well, he he occupies
a space, I guess, with a bunch of people who have been friends
for like a decade, right? Like all the other people who kind
of operate around him have been friends for a long time. So,
look at this. I hope Willie is trolling. Surely he's not this
much of a Right. Surely surely
surely Willy's okay. Willy will be okay. Right. Right
guys.
Um, God, why why would they do this? Hold on. I'm looking trying
to
see. Remember when Nicholas used to be in Spicy or this Discord?
I don't I didn't realize that they thought I do. They think I
don't understand how I get referenced that much that like Tommy
C knows who I am. Even though, right? Like that has to be all
behind the scenes. I don't know what they think I'm doing over
here. Like, do you know what I mean? I like Quinnman in terms
of making this happen. I do nothing. I just like exist over here
covering completely different I talk to these guys all the time.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't know the I have no idea what could
be getting said. I don't know. Remember when you had D on here
a bunch of times? I do. What
What did you do?
I think it was literally the I think it was literally the argument
with Lily like set these people off like massively. Oh. Oh. Oh,
hold on. Never mind. It is just Riyle, isn't it? I'm just getting
blamed for Riyle's.
I am. No, but that's 100% what it is. Is he looks at that channel,
he's like, "You must own that channel." And I don't I don't control
it. And he calls Nicholas fat all the time. I'm like, "Bro,
I I You think I condone calling people fat for no reason?" No,
I do not. The
You call Nick fat all the time? I I did go and pop up uh Aiden
with just Nick the eating the pie. You use that constantly. You're
actually always using that.
I don't use it constantly. It gets linked to me constantly if
Nick is a topic of conversation. That's not my fault. What do
you mean? How would that be my fault,
dude? Extreme dad, go be a somewhere else, please. Right. Extreme
dad's making posts. Listen, extreme dad. Extreme dad's doing
things, okay? I went on Mr. Girl's hotline tonight to ask him
for help owning you with my destining arguments. He was not amused.
It's isn't content. I wonder why. Wild.
Where is Can I look at this clip live?
Live. I actually want to go to this subreddit right now and see
the Shimu thread cuz is is there really a thread of them? Oh,
no, not really. Thoughts on Tommy C calling out Chud Logic? Let's
check this out. What are they saying?
Uh, I missed this being caught up on the drama. Can someone give
me a summary of what Tommy called Chut out for? Calling out Nick
and Auggie during RFC Mania, associating with snakes, Queenman,
Jtock, etc. The New Year's stream leaking bowax info plus pressuring
Tom boosting the kinetic help. He thinks Chud might be another
crows of judgment. I agree with Tommy's stance on Chud to be
honest. I think Chud does what he does to get content and I can't
blame him for that. And to be honest, where I feel Chud has overstepped
in the past has he has ended up being right on the right side.
Uh where I think Chud has overstepped in the past, he has ended
up being on the right side. Namely, Boax and more prominently
calling Mudahar a snake back at the start of the Mama Max drama.
Yes, but I wouldn't trust What's wrong with that?
Uh I mean this is I literally they're never going to say it,
but it's literally criticizing the person I like. That's it.
That's going to be ex exactly like they need to say this and
just be really open and honest
by I I I'm sus about Chut because even though he still he ends
up right in all these situations if he shut the up, no one would
have to be giving mud a harsh. No one would have to give Bo or
something like that, right? It's not like it's not like Chad
has made any wrong judgments on people, has he?
Um, I mean, he definitely misjudged the age of that trans person.
Wait, what? You don't know about the
Oh, is this the um the old allegations? Yeah, the Indian face
in the DMs.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it is. So, that's just the case. And I'm I'll
give him that. He misjudged. That's it. Right. He didn't He didn't
get it. No, he's not actually. Don't
That was such a stupid drama or situation.
Yeah, I still have never covered it. Listen, I'm I'm I'm just
looking the other way, okay? I know that there might be something
there. I've never looked into it. I'm looking the other way,
Chud. Okay, long as I get to stay in spicy chat, we're all good.
I'll look the other way on whatever you've done with the 17-year-old
trans person.
Oh, boy.
I had blew it in my mouth there. I was drinking my water. That
was almost a disaster. The little boy. Who says that? I had fluids
in my mouth. Is that like Canadian? No.
Uh, no. I only see Extreme Dad laughing in chat when this guy
was talking to little boys as well. Oh, hold on. Just I we I
didn't even finish this comment, but I wouldn't trust Chud at
all if I was a content creator. Besides, I think a big part of
this uh of this is members of the community demanding Nick and
another content creator cover any cover another topic. But like
why would he? The paychecks are just fine covering EHD. Why cover
obscure stuff that won't pay as well? Where whose criticism of
Nicholas Deorio is that he won't cover other things? Yeah, I
don't know. Yeah, this is like a totally fabricated
thing. I would love like do any of these people talk? No,
I don't think Chad associ associates with Chuck. Wrong
wrong. Hold on. Wrong
wrong. being in spicy chat is associating with uh with Chud.
That's
Uh I've got DMs with Chud. Okay, they exist. I think we should
I think we should actually start encouraging that idea that everyone
in spicy chat. Yeah, listen. If the ADL wants to look into Chud
logic. All right. He's got an alt in spicy chat. It goes by the
ID deeper. If the ADL wants to look into that, okay, please go
ahead get to the bottom of why Chud really hates the ADL. It's
more comfortable. It's more It's I'm more charitable to Chud
because he's contentrained and he really doesn't care. I don't
think it's snake behavior, but it's just contentrained. I thought
it was a good point Chud kept making this morning, Cherry. I
don't know what you think about this, but Chud kept making the
point like, "How can you call me a snake when I consistently
move in the open? You're calling me a snake for saying, "Hey,
you're being a bit like a bit uh one-sided with your coverage
on this." Like, where's the snakiness? He just said his opinion
in the public. Is there some snake- like element there? Is he
operating in the shadows? Not in any way. Right.
The unfortunate part is that I believe a lot of the people who
might look at him like a snake right now thought that he was
one of the good ones when this was kind of how he moved through
the leftist community, right? You are in this community. You
have beliefs very similar to these people. But one by one, you
start seeing that the people around you are pretty off and you
don't go out of your way for them anymore even though they're
like expecting you to because they're doing some weird stuff.
That's like where Chud was and that's why Chud, I think, drifted
towards the commentary. They started looking at him like he was
one of the good ones. He's like a leftist who uh didn't mind
making like edgy jokes or having like decent takes. He's not
like too extreme or whatever.
They liked him when he maneuvered his way through there, but
I guess if he's like maneuvering through them now. Maybe don't
like being uh one of the people he's passing by.
Yeah, I would love to see some of these people like watch Chud's
response cuz the other point he made is like cuz it's really
funny when Tommy goes, "Hey, listen. You're a snake. when we
talk about you behind the scenes, we all discuss how we are not
gonna go. We're not gonna go on your show anymore. So, you're
a snake. It's like, oh, so you're all discussing me behind my
back in some private group chat to discuss how I am a snake because
of my publicly stated opinion. Okay, cool. I guess
I think listen, I don't I don't give Quman a lot of credit for
the calls, but waterrained, I have no idea why that stream existed
or happened. like just it gave away so many things. Yes, Tommy
C is waterbrained. Waterbrain boomer. Okay. Chug got really big
on YT drama because they said they don't like him, but he always
ends up being right. Uh I think it's just cuz they really like
I don't know. It's when you watch everything, you tend to get
a good picture. And a lot of people just I think there's just
this thing that happens once you get big enough in any space
in online entertainment, you can start phoning it in pretty hard.
And when you're on the come up, I I think people just don't phone
it. It is hard. I don't know. You guys
appeasing like the the networking social pressure, right? Don't
do anything to rock the boat. This is really good income. I look
out for you. You look out for me. Here's that one time you have
my back. And then all of a sudden 10 years go down and this person
is like, you have to defend me even though
I like how did I end up here?
Um, yeah, exactly. I that's that's where my like uh sort of understanding
for Nick's dilemma was was like I don't think I think it's really
hard to tell when you get like ma a massive influx of audience
right out of nowhere. It's pretty hard to tell you're making
like a bunch of money where you're looking over like uh sorry
overlooking things because you like it's hard to perceive that
yourself. You kind of need other people around you to point it
out. is very difficult when you're when you got a ton of praise
getting heaped on you, a ton of money, a ton of new viewers,
and but somebody like nobody's you're not ever going to be able
to check yourself on that because you see all the success. You're
never going to be able to go, wait, am I doing this correctly?
It's like almost impossible. So, you kind of need other people
to call you out. I think I feel um a little bit there. I think
for a lot of the people in this space, it's whenever content
creators cut off the ability to interact with like opposing ideas
or like have debates over some of their takes, that's when
Right. That's like the first red flag that you're off off the
tracks. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Um that you're basically or Yeah.
you you either cut people off or Yeah. you just don't engage
with certain criticisms at all. Right. Like uh Queen made this
point last night which was if they're calling you a like you
don't have to engage, right? Assuming you're not credibly being
accused. If they're just calling you like insane, but if they're
just giving like a criticism of one of your takes or your content
style or something, it's like you should be able to read that,
listen to it, and like engage and
back. And if you can't do that, yeah, it's obviously that's the
beginning of the Well, I feel like when you're in commentary,
yeah, this is the other thing, Cherry, is like when you're in
commentary, you're literally critiquing people. Like you have
to be able to do that, right? Like that's literally the job.
That's also what's really hard for me cuz like I take some of
the commentary people's like opinions seriously. Other times
they just seem like they're intentionally being a joke. Do you
know what I mean?
Like you guys sometimes have that one guy who will come on here
with the the um
what is his name? It's like a little kid. Not Quan. Another one
even younger. Aiden. And I feel like Yeah, that guy he I feel
like he almost intentionally tries to have like stupid or like
Mr. intentionally tries to have stupid. I don't have to like
that can't be serious, right? I think Mau and Aiden operate significant.
Aiden is like a calculated I'm going to say the most he's like
he wants to get, you know, a true or false test like a 0% on
a true or false test. I think that's like Aiden's content style
in a
nutshell. He might really hate that. He's trying to show you
that he knows what's what's true by proving that he can be like
the perfect. And Mau is Malo is uh like smart but also gets really
emotional. And I think that's awesome for content. I actually
know that's awesome for content. Some people don't appreciate
it though cuz sometimes he'll get emotional in your direction
and then they just don't like it.
Like he'll say you did something weird with a
Dude, by the way, literally won that conversation with the Cheeto,
right? Like on Bloomman's stream. Like he completely won that
conversation. Even though everybody blew him up for that drama,
he absolutely like the Cheeto. Like it's because the thing is
everyone blew him up for that drama or everyone was blowing him
up. And I like kind of agreed with moral and I gave like a kind
of, you know, better worded version of the take to Aiden and
Aiden agreed with that. and then just sort of went to rest and
then when it was like back in the cold light of day all of a
sudden they was like no I think I actually agree with moral after
the geo conversation
okay someone blew moral up for absolutely nothing in that conversation
cuz he didn't uh express himself very well basically poop my
pants off says they're all so they all talk in group chats and
run with decisions and narratives from there it's cowardly behavior
hey you don't have to tell me that I literally have messaged
these people like eight times being like Hey, you want to talk
like off stream? Like, hey, I regret that like apparently we're
enemies now and you guys have to like talk me. I'll chat with
you guys if you want to talk. And I just get I don't get a response.
So, you don't have to tell me that like these guys have like
a uniform opinion. Seems to be the case.
And by the way, I don't know where Tommy C got this or where
he says it like a couple times like I demanded these people debate
me. No, I just said I literally think I asked Nick and spicy
chat. I could I don't want to get into like yeah I don't want
to leak the DMs. But I literally was just like hey if you want
to chat I just know you didn't like my coverage but I was like
hey if you want to chat about it and he said yeah we will.
I imagine that they just don't like the optics of announcing
that
um they won't talk to you or debate you.
I guess so. Right. They want that. They want that like professional
courtesy that you just hold that privately and just publicly
say stuff like I would love to talk to him. I'm not saying that
you have to or um that that's like a better option, but generally
this probably you know what gets under their skin is the optics
of looking like they don't want to talk to you. I So I would
agree in most cases. Not in this case though because I've said
it multiple times.
Yeah. Yeah. That's like actually No, but that's what I mean.
No. No. You've literally talked about it in a way where it's
like uh he said he would talk to me. He said twice he would talk
to me and he just doesn't and he hasn't. I would love to debate
them. So you make it very clear that they won't come and talk
to you. And so that's already that's already like stabbing the
ego,
Sure. I understand how saying the truth could stab the ego. Yeah,
I got it. Yeah, for real.
People who just find out that they won't talk to you and already
think negatively of them.
Um, sure. You would hope.
Uh, well, I don't know. Maybe. But I it's not even like dude
again it's it's like I I think Nick thought that I like wanted
to debate him and then he was like oh also he could see that
there were like some holes in Willy's stuff and I think he didn't
want to talk about it but I didn't even want to debate him. I
was just going to be like hey yeah there's like more what I thought
if you think that's then that's fine.
Yeah. I don't know.
That was funny as he he did and unfortunately I watched that
and just laugh my ass off about it. So that's probably why they
also don't like me. I might have said some crazy in that when
I watched it, too. I think I had like I think I had some booze
when I watched that and just went I might have gone off. I I
don't really remember. I remember Riyle thought it was really
funny. Um that's not Yeah, I might have I might have gone off
there. Okay, Riyle also thinks it's very funny to make women
obese in his thumbnails.
That is funny. That's like what I hate Riyle's AI, but the making
Aerodite fat and all that's like that is just funny.
Unfortunately, very very funny. We got Man, it'd be cool to just
like ask I I seriously just want like any of these people to
talk. Like I swear to God, I can be like so soft and nice to
these people. I just want them to like come on. It's so It's
so weird to me that I can't get anybody to join the stream. I'm
like, "Dude, we we just talk about this like opinion you have."
It's like people actually know that their opinions have no basis
at all and they couldn't possibly talk about it and that doesn't
bother them. It's very weird to me. You know what I mean? Like
like one of these people will comment on Twitter or something.
I'll just be like, "Hey, you come like talk like I don't have
to debate you. What do I have to debate?" It's like, "No, I literally
just talk. Just talk." It's literally the name.
Sorry. This bothers me and then I rant about it. You guys can
just, you know, you got any other topics? You guys want to talk
about anything else?
Hello. No. Okay.
Oh, Queen just went super robotic. Is that just me? If you and
Quimman are gropers, how do I differentiate myself from you guys?
I'm not a groper.
Um, I'm actually unaware of you guys being gropers. This is news
to me. Yeah, I think that will have that will just eventually
get transferred over. I think it's crazy that like why I don't
know why the commentary pickle uh people pick up these talking
points. I actually don't get it at all. I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know. Cherry. Why?
I Yeah,
you don't get why they would pick up the Oh, right. I remember
who first gave you that emmo of being um bird juice.
Yeah, I I just don't Yeah, I there's like some kind of thing
going on here that I am too autistic to understand at all. It's
unfortunate. No, you're just not autistic enough.
Maybe I also I don't even know where to go. Dye, what?
I think it's red 45. Is that the color of food dye that can cause
um something to happen with your brain in development?
Oh, okay. Yeah. That's why you shouldn't let um little kids drink
Hawaiian Punch. Something like that. Oh, it's red 40. My bad.
Red 40. Okay, cool.
Um Marty, thank you for the five gifted. Appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you. Thank you.
I'm going to keep reading some of these comments cuz um I'm just
I'm wondering if anybody has like honestly solid points in any
of this. I just I want to see what the thoughts are. It wasn't
until I saw the video that it occurred to me that Nick hasn't
mentioned Chud that much recently. And Tommy is right that the
Boax stress thing wasn't an accident. I mean, sure.
Even if that is true, I don't know if that's the same thing.
Like, what what's the backdrop of that? Is that that Chud is
like getting DMs and they're calling Bob Blacks a total freak
that none of them like anymore? Like, if that's the case, then
I don't know that obviously going to be the tone of conversation.
Obviously, that was the tone of my conversations with Nick. Like,
it's like, yeah, Bob's Yeah, it sucks this guy. Yeah. So I like
if if they were like, "Oh, it's really concerning that this guy's
wearing I think he's having a mental breakdown." And then Chud
was like, "Hey, you guys hear about this freak wearing a dress?"
Then yeah, that's kind of sneaky. They were trying to get something
done there. Sounds like they were all just laughing at this guy
behind the scenes. Which again, is Chud the snake there? I don't
know. Uh Marty, thank you for the five gifted though. Awesome.
Oh, did you know this is unrelated to Warren Smith is going to
go on the Whatever podcast. That's awesome. Yeah, I won't make
fun of him. I forgot he was a conservative. I'm just like watching
him glaze Andrew
Like he's uh Well, what
is he a conservative? I don't know if we call him a conservative.
Hold on. What I should do? I should move us over to I think I'm
not in a channel that any of the other people could join if they
were watching. I'm just going to move us. Are we in the wrong
Discord? Uh, no. This is like the commentary people discord.
They all have they could join this room if they wanted. Yeah.
Just just in case like uh Aiden or somebody wanted to join right
now while we're talking about this. Should be in this room cuz
I would I think we even have like some other commentary people
in this Discord. If any of them were watching like I would I
don't know. I'd take comments from like almost any of them basically.
Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Do you have any clips from about his coverage?
Oh actually we didn't even watch that. Yeah. Oh, wait. That's
a fantastic point, Jerry. That we didn't even watch that on stream.
I can literally watch that cover. I'm so surprised. Like, it's
the first time I ever had a fantastic point.
Uh, no. It's me being like surprised and disappointed with myself
for not realizing that it's the obvious direction we should be
going in.
Why are you surprised at the disappointment you feel for yourself?
It
turn the stream again. It's It's actually unforgivable.
It's crazy. He's just got bullied into Twin Stream over there.
That's actually insane.
I called Kim from a parking lot. I'm like, "Hey, I'm driving
around. I can't Nothing. I can't.
Why do you go live like Zena?
That would have an epic car crash out stream." I said to like
drive around. Nothing going on. Uh I could I couldn't do anything
in my house yesterday for some reason. And I I literally was
out for a drive so I could have so I can do. So I like joined
spicy started talking to Quman and you saw him sitting in there.
God. Okay. I think I think basically from the very beginning
Chud goes live and he starts talking about Tommy about an individual.
Yeah. Like serious.
It's just Do you want to present great veterans? Uh no I'm good.
I'm going to watch this on my own. Kind of hurt my feelings.
You kind of hurt my feelings a little bit. Kind of okay to watch
this by myself. Oh we go. Dude, really? Now you scan back and
or in the spot right here. Right here.
No, I'm here. I'm here, guys. I'm here. I did say that I'd do
a stream yesterday from an
Um, but basically by the time it got to like my kids were asleep,
um, it just wasn't worth streaming. It was like 10 p.m. So, I
just went to bed instead. So, sorry about that. Apologies. I
know you get very disappointed if you say that I'm going to stream
and then I don't stream. Um but but yeah, that's wonderful. But
how do I make money off press people? Oh my god. Jesus Christ,
guys. It just started. I'm literally one minute into my stream.
Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make money off people emoji?
Geriatric commentator Thomas C. Literally can't even finish explaining.
Can't even finish explaining and apologizing for not streaming
yesterday. You guys are desperate for me to a geriatric veteran
with with CTE. No. Come on. It's banter. It's banter. Come on.
Come on, guys. It's all banter. It's all banter. Okay. It's all
banter from me. It's all banter. No. No. Listen. Listen. Okay.
I know that people are expecting me to do some sort of like crazed,
you know, joining against Tommy C.
So,
ape rape. Yeah. And there was never anything on Tommy C. Anyway,
Chud I
He's misleading here, isn't he? Yeah, there was a scop on on
Tommy C. There was an ape on Willie Mac and Chud is is ignoring
the fact that he called ape creek on Nicholas Stri. He's trying
to avoid that. He called. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, he did. He backed
off. Did he say you have like the exact quote, Quayman? Just
so Yeah. He said, "I'm I'm chimping out. Uh I'm chimping the
out. I'm calling Abe Craig Q Nicholas Dioro and he started making
monkey noises. I mean, for the sake of it, you should probably
make the monkey noises.
Did you overpower him? Um, no. He he just uh cooled down. It
It he called down. It was a moment of exuberance. Oh,
Why are you trying to get him to make monkey noises?
I don't want to be here for that. No, no, thank you.
Um, I mean, what'd you say? What' you say, dude? What do you
say? The great, one of the great veterans of commentary, Tommy
C, tragically no longer trusts me. That is obviously very disappointing
to uh to I just have to laugh and make it very clear that this
is no loss to him whatsoever. It's kind of upointing to see.
I can't be trusted
Um Oh, wait. I forgot.
We should actually Has anybody talked to Hellbent on a stream
about like her clear betrayal of Nicholas Doro
just for content for your stream?
I don't I don't know. I don't think so. Um some some mod came
to Queman came to Quan's chat, Cherry, and told Queman, just
so you know, Nicholas is deleting any mentions of you or Jtock
in his chat right now. Or you and Chud. I think it was you and
Chud and banning like anybody who uh mentions you. Yeah. And
that's like one of the mods.
The base stand up comedian. She linked me her stuff. We could
watch some of her stuff after this.
And you can continue to tell me how based and awesome it is.
What do you think? I will. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we'll
see. Dude, what do I say? What do I say about this? What is there
to say? What is there to say, dude? Well, I'm laughing cuz it's
so [__] stupid, bro. It's all so [__]
Dude, it's just absurd. It's totally absurd, bro. I made a few
comments on stream about some of my issues. I mean, look, the
comments that I made on stream were a quarter were like a third
Finny rage, okay? They were like a third Finny rage. They were
a third like serious issues and they were like a third banter,
okay? And yeah, I do have some issues. I do have some problems.
I'm not going to go over all my comments again. Obviously, I've
already said them. If anyone's got a problem with my take on
something that I've I've spoken about an individual and they've
got like an issue with something that I've said about them,
Then I'm willing to talk about it and I can do that on stream,
off stream, you know, record the call if you think I'm a snake
and I'm going to snake him in some way. That's wonderful. But
how do I make money off, you know? I'm like an open door. Ch
stole Tommy's BB.
I can't I don't know if I can say anything. I will say something,
bro. They all hang out with Aiden and Aiden doesn't snake people,
but I will say that if you ever snake Aiden, any conversation
you've ever been in with him, okay, that's on his hard drive.
All right.
He's a freak. He's EB recording
audio cuz too actually stands for Thank you for super chats.
Nothing wrong with that. Okay. Probably
something wrong with No, there's something wrong with if spiritually
Indian. He's spiritually Indian. That guy smiles all the time.
There you see what you do for a living. There's not that many
reasons to be smiling. Nobody can be that happy doing. You guys
are actually soed up. If I go on camp, I'm going to be just like
I smile all the time. I'm happy generally. Do you smile? Yeah,
I smile all the time.
I smile as a strategy. Don't you know if you like force yourself
to smile, that actually causes you to get like happy feelings?
Like when men tell women you should smile more, they're really
just looking out for them. Yeah, true.
I don't think anyone was looking out for me when they said that.
I'm just I'm telling you that's how it is. Depressing angry face.
Yeah,
I smile because I'm depressed. Same, bro. John smoking. I'm smiling
because uh all my childhood dreams are dead. I've not made it
to I've not I've not actually achieved my potential in any way.
And there is no getting better. It will only slowly get worse
for the rest of my life. Okay? And I'm come to terms with that
and I'm dead inside. So, I smile to make myself feel something,
you know? I figure you being like a Canadian, I figure you'd
get over that like a real early age. I like that. What is this?
This is something. Somebody sent me this and said you should
pull this up and Aiden will come and defend it. What it seems
like to me. Oh, I know Aiden has some
What? What's going on behind the scenes? Aiden, you're in all
these You're all You have all these Why can't you just tell us?
Um, anything that I could leak, which I won't leak cuz then nobody
will tell me in private, you could just figure out by watching
this. Is it just Willie and Tom in private group chats about
the fact that Chuck them or what? No, I don't talk to I haven't
spoken to Tom in a long time. I guarantee you Turkey Tom is not
complaining about this. And I guarantee you Turkey Tom can handle
this better. But the Biden saying Aiden's saying it's obvious
from what he's saying, so I'm just going by the the You have
to read between the lines. Ask yourself some of the claims Tommy's
making. How could he possibly know them? Yes. Exactly. Exactly.
Yes. Where is Tommy getting this from? Yes,
you. Okay, Aiden basically just leaks that yes, they are all
complaining in these group chats to Tommy. Good enough. Good
enough. Thanks, Aiden. Thanks, Aiden. Aiden's the the best double
agent, isn't he? I mean, I hate to use the phrase dual loyalty,
but
yeah,
he was originally a citizen of he was a citizen of the commentary
community, and now he's a citizen of whatever this thing is.
Okay.
He's only loyal to one regime. What is Namba? Uh, Nando. Nando
is like a I think it's a fast food chicken place, but they also
sell like their sauce became more familiar than the actual restaurant,
right? The Perry Perry sauce. Am I crazy? I never heard of that
place. Maybe outside the UK, the sauce may famous, but uh people
know the restaurant here, I think. Yeah, it's a South African
restaurant. I think it was originally. Yeah, it's a South African
restaurant. Yeah.
food. Let's see here. Our food. So, they actually have a restaurant
and then they sell the they sell this. Do we have them in Canada?
I don't know. I don't know that I've ever been to a Nando, but
I do know that they sell like Perry Perry sauce everywhere. I'm
not sure I've been to one, but I've I've definitely bought Perry
Perry sauce. I might have like a big thing of Perry Perry sauce
in my fridge right now to be honest with you. We do have them.
Okay, I'll take you guys for it. That's so guy of you.
What's that? Oh, do I have a massive thing of Dude, this hot
sauce has been in my fridge since I moved into this place. Yeah,
I know. It's up. That hot sauce has got to go, actually, now
that I think about
Yeah, there. Perry Perry mayo is unreal. Oh, all right. J talks
so fat he knows every detail about fast food restaurants he's
never been to. I said, I've got the sauce. And then I Googled
it as South African, bro. What do you want from me? What do you
want from me? Open the door. If you want to talk to me, you can
talk to me. I'm literally like a DM away, you know. Just drop
me a message if you got like some problem with what I said. The
crazy thing about this new Tommy rant is that like I didn't even
mention the guy and he's like raging at me saying I'm not trustworthy
or some [__] you know? Brings up my allegation, says
like, "Dude, what the was that as well?" He like bore up my allegation,
framed it in an insane way, and then said people look the other
way about it, which isn't what happened at all. Enjoy the tomato
soup since the last street.
you. That was that was the dumbest thing I've ever Oh my god.
You know what? I looked the other way. But not the craziest just
self own. It's just like why you said that I literally can't
understand. You know, he's talking about this my stupid allegation
from coming up on Yeah. So Tommy said he he looked that um with
Chud's thing of texting the 17-year-old.
He said, "Uh, let's not forget you. You were little boys and
uh we all looked the other way on it." Jeez. It's like, "What
do you mean you looked the It was you. We all looked the other
way." It's like, "What do you mean you look the other way, bro?
Everyone else looked it and and thought, oh, they
misunders. It's not, you know, there's no big big issue here
really." Um, and then Tommy's like, "Well, no, I thought it was
up. I just didn't say anything. I just wanted to keep the connection.
This guy thought that Chud was talking to little boys and he
just ignored it.
He looked the other way. Yeah.
Until Chud said something bad about Nicholas Deorio. And then
Tommy realized that is wrong after all.
You never think so. But
what is wrong with these people? I have no idea.
I Okay, I gotta I gotta imagine most of the other people are
around that space. It's pinball machines. Does he have arcade
machines around him? What kind of machines are these? Tommy C
has pinball machines. So does Nick Dioro. So does Brianna Woo.
Yeah. No, they're arcade machines. But yeah, these are all arcade
cabinets. But I think that's what Brianna Woo has, too. Nick
is smarter than both of those people. Nick, I'm never going to
call Nick like a bumbling. Nick is smart. He's just um you know
he's uh blinded a little bit right now.
Well, is it him? Because this does seem like a Well, the broader
thing was a complaint about Nick, but then Tommy has uh latched
on to Nick's feelings about obviously Nick felt a little bit
hurt by it or something, expressed that behind the scenes, and
then Tommy's just gone, you know, you dare across Tommy's internet
nephew, it's over. Cringe.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, I'll hit play on this. 5 years ago now should
probably at all you know when do this no don't just fire it up
and then get 3 seconds in and then yap. Sorry I'm yapping. Samson
tried to propose I was glad you paused for that. I I like to
just pause and explain things to people just for like no real
reason because I've learned that this actually infuriates Cherry
every time I do it. So sometimes I'll just pause and explain
like very very mundane inane things to people and then I'll just
continue on with the content and know that she's seen because
of what happened. Name name one thing you've ever explained on
this stream and it made sense. Done Pete. Uh Ry, thank you for
the five gifted.
I can't name one.
Exactly. Yeah. There you go. Cuz if that's what you're doing,
Nick and others became a member. Celebrates two months of membership.
Tommy went full Elon Musk on you. Thank you very much for the
membership. You know, they were defending me because I was getting
called a and they thought it was unreasonable on the basis of
the evidence that Noah Samson was presenting. And that was before
I was even really speaking to them. That was before I even really
knew them that well. They did it just off their own back. There
was there was no like, you know, pressure or anything as far
as I know to do it. I certainly wasn't applying any pressure
21 to defend me over it. You know, if people want to criticize
me for it, that's up to them at the end of the day. But there's
no I don't know enough for another hour. Yeah, I'm going we're
going for a while anyway, Ry. Um, I'm not like adding it up,
but thank you for the donation and it's probably be another hour
for any pressure for me to do anything about it, you know, and
so it's just bizarre that he's now like, you know, acting like
there is some substance to it. Do you know what I mean? He's
acting like there's some sort of substance to it and that people
look the other way on it, which I was never my impression from
how people spoke about it. My impression was that people looked
at it and thought it was bogus and said as much and that's truly
what they believed. You know, certainly don't say that you think
something's okay if you genuinely don't like speak your mind
about it. If you think I'm some sort of nons, say that I'm a
nons and we'll we know where we stand. I've never asked anyone
to defend me over the what happened 5 years ago now, you know.
But people of their own accord have defended me because they
thought what I was getting called for what happened was obviously
like some sort of, you know, insane overstatement of the situation.
I'm trying to be calm. I'm trying to be calm, by the way. I'm
not trying to stoke more flames on the fire and start more stupid
drama. But it Why though?
Why? It's one of those things where um drama. We want to see
stupid drama. It's it's really unfortunate cuz here is somewhere
where Israel was just always correct. Okay. Sometimes the only
way to defend yourself is to have, you know, an iron fist in
in that can go with the iron wall. You know what I'm saying?
Like you you actually can't just sit there passively. You like
give people the benefit of the doubt. You're like, "Oh, I don't
want to make more drama." Sometimes you have to hit them back
if they're going to make drama with you for no reason. Okay.
That's that's what it is. It is obviously frustrating for someone
to bring bring, you know, try and relitigate this 5-year-old
drama. Funnily enough, I think IO was streaming about it yesterday
as well. And if you want to talk about it, that's fine. Talk
about it. Have you say about it, call me a notch, whatever you
want to do, right? But I'm not looking to endlessly reciprocate
something that happened 5 years ago. The Gawk jokes are enough.
The Gawk jokes are enough. Okay? The [__] jokes are
enough for me to deal with that I don't have to endlessly talk
about, you know, some obviously embarrassing [__]
that I did 5 years ago that I unreasonably got called agreement
with. So that was probably the most, you know, frustrating part
of his video. It's like, why why are you talking about it like
you were looking the other way and you actually had a problem
with it or something? I don't know. It was very bizarre. It's
totally bizarre, you know, like do you have a problem with it?
Don't you have a problem with it? You know, are you saying that
because I got offended on one thing? Juck has unresolved race
issues. STV Philly, why would you come in and say that apppropo
of nothing? Where was a ra I haven't made a racial comment for
like 15 minutes. That's bordering on a record for me. What do
you mean I have unresolved race issues?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure they're solved by getting to say what he
says on stream. Keep up.
This is uh katharsis. Okay, I get it. I get all the racism out
on stream and then I can go into the world and not say the it's
awesome. I've got to like what? be gracious at all times and
and you know defend thing. I I don't know what he's asking me
to do off the back of that, you know. And the other thing as
well, I've been very gracious. I have been exceptionally gracious
in dealing with a lot of this. Okay. How does any of this make
me a snake? That's the other thing that I don't understand. How
am I a snake? What have I done that's snaky? I'm finding out
for the first time that apparently people don't want to come
on my stream anymore, right? For the first time, I'm hearing
this and apparently that makes me a snake. Is it some sort of
group chat? some sort of mean girls group chat that you guys
have got where you talk about not wanting to come on my stream
anymore because I'm a snake and and that makes me the snake apparently
and that makes me the snake is is you not wanting to come on
my stream and apparently well Tommy is saying this I don't know
how [__] broad this is who is who are these people
he's that's the that's the good stuff right there okay that he
gives he just gives everybody else the out it's like if you guys
want you don't have to defend this this from this okay you can
just you can actually just disavow him completely and move on.
That's That's awesome. Okay, that's that's strategic thinking,
guys. I don't I think Tommy might be out on a a total limb here
and all you guys have to do is say that yeah, he's uh he's speaking,
you know, he's just shooting off for no reason and he's dumb
and then we can move forward. Who wants to be who Listen, all
of these people, they seem to be mostly concerned with the number
of subscribers people have or like the number of viewers they
get, right? I think that's mostly it. And Ch's just betting on
that. He's saying, "Listen, you want to go with this guy who
gets like 10 viewers, or you want to go with me who gets like
uh 1,000
viewers?" I I think it's a pretty easy choice for them naming
these people. Is this true? I don't [__] know. It's
the first I've heard of it. It's the first I've [__]
heard of it, dude. I've not heard that people don't want to come
on my stream because they think I'm some sort of snake. But think
about how utterly bizarre that is as well, right? Think about
how absurd that is, too. People don't want to have a publicly
broadcasted conversation with me because I'm a snake. Okay. Well,
it's happening publicly. It's happening
publicly. So, where's the snake? You know, I have been very gracious
and I've said to people, wonderful. Thank you for the super chat.
Off to press people.
Thank you. I said to people, don't keep it coming. Come on. Keep
it coming.
I want some money. Come on. Let's go. If we're going to be if
we're going to snake these off, I'll get paid for it. Also, dude,
I'm not snaking anyone. I've got no interest in snaking anyone.
I've been very gracious about a number of different things throughout
my time doing this. And I'll always try and, you know, pursue
a conversation. Even privately, if someone's got an issue and
a disagreement, I'm happy to, you know, yeah, have a conversation.
Why? Wait, why does he do that? He says, "How am I a snake? It
all happens in the public." But he said twice now that he'll
have private conversations. Uh, I think he will do that at their
behest. Yeah, I think he's saying like, "I would rather have
a public conversation, but if you need a private one, I can do
that for you." Oh, like they would just think that if they talk
to him publicly, he's going to do something.
or that like some way, right? Yeah. Like if they have criticisms,
if he has criticisms for them, like I think he's just saying
we could discuss it publicly or privately. If you don't want
to discuss it publicly, but like it's it's he's bending to them.
I think he always would always would have a preference for a
public conversation. You can do that. Okay. But but was it not
sneaky when he pulled Queenman in the call to confront
Um actually, I was going to say it was definitely sneaky when
he did it to Tommy C. He knew Tommy was going to die. It wasn't
it wasn't snaking. No, but it wasn't Queman. It was the other
person. Wait, what do you mean?
Why do I want to call him Snaggletoothoth? Who am I thinking
of? Smaggle. Oh, yeah. Wait, Smaggle. Smaggle pulled me. Yeah,
Chud didn't pull me up like Snaggle did. Yeah, but how up is
it that he gets to bring in Smaggle, so he's like, I didn't bring
Queen in. Smaggle did it.
That was kind of funny though. What did he do? Queman, come on
down. Come on down. That was a crazy call though cuz didn't Queman
play chicken with him? Like Yeah. So that's Yeah. Tell us about
No. No. Go ahead. Tell me about your childhood trauma. Good times.
That was um But the Tommy C one I It's okay. You could say it's
not snaky, but when I I don't know. I'd have to go watch it again
because for some reason I want to say Chud said something like
my friend Queen just doesn't really he he's not a huge fan of
yours and again I think that was not enough poisoning of the
well I think reiterated he said twice he said first round he
said he's I've been highly critical I've had very harsh words
and then he said and then he said something like he can be a
bit bit aggressive and and Tommy was like yeah yeah I'll talk
to him I'll talk to him
so Tommy C no complaints Sure. I think Chud knew what was going
to happen though. Maybe maybe he he's definitely covered himself
with those comments. If he said he's been very critical of you
he said some very harsh words for you, then yeah, he's covered.
So So are we looking at Chad like he is Hutch just pulling people
in when like the demon is tapped out?
No. Well, okay. Tommy. I mean, sorry. It is the same thing like
like Tommy would be just naturally defenseless in that situation,
but like it it wasn't like he had hours of Tommy being like totally
defenseless to go on or something. I don't know. I think it's
different.
But I I like my head. Muhar is some he's a massive guy who never
talks never debates anyone and he has come in purely to beat
on some and does nothing. Yeah, Tommy C theoretically and and
even in public opinion at the time did come out on top, but you
know, optimally it's probably soured since dude, I think. Yeah.
So, he he should be able to defend himself uh against some coming
on who's got, you know, nothing. I've got nothing going on at
that point. So,
is Mudap like shameless?
Yes. Yeah. Does he experience shame? Because I swear all of the
things that he is guilty of, I watch him throw that same like
the same criticism for behaving that way to um Idubbbz's wife.
Was it Anise? Yeah, Muhar's piggy wife is always seething about
Ana on Twitter and it's very obvious that it's because his piggy
wife is is very tubby and Ana is is a skinny above average woman
and she clearly can't handle that. Okay. When did women turn
into like a petty housewife? What the I just I look for what's
going to get on someone's skin. I think that that's the that's
the line. Yeah, that that's going to do it. What do you mean
turn into? That is the most catty thing to point out. Like, oh,
you ever watch this guy's content? This person hates this girl.
I'm just saying she she's a hobby white woman who has married
an Indian man. I thought Muslims weren't allowed to eat pork.
That was haram. Well, I'm not getting past that point. I'm not
getting racism. True.
Uh, okay. Fair enough. I love you were saying something about
like uh the the criticisms that he throws at Idam's wife like
apply to him.
I don't like fat
Um, yeah, he you would have to watch the video. He has like a
video recently came out criticizing the whole Idubbbz thing with
Creator
Clash. He Okay.
What? Where was the anti- drama?
He was or he said so. It's in my head, but I chose not to say
it.
Why are you
Okay.
Shouldn't talk about it. Even if it doesn't happen publicly,
you can record it, release it, whatever. If you're that worried
about being a snake, you know, I'm quite an open book. I'm not
someone who's going to like go around discreetly and talk in
like different group chats and talk all this about people and
go to this person that hates that person. Oh, by the way, I don't
know that Mudhar's wife is fat. I totally disavow those comments
from Quimman. I've never even seen a picture of her. Okay. Yeah.
No, totally disavow. Totally disavow Queen's comments there.
Dude, you know what's gay as well is this loser Mahar. That was
this [__] where it's like these people talk about
my wife and all this. He's always said about me cuz he would
never even he is actually smarter than to bring attention to
me. But
uh he does this where he's people talk about my wife and all
this. So, bro, your wife is out there crying about drama and
on Twitter day in day out. You he literally uses one of her tweets
in his video at one point. It's like so [__] it's
so gay that people are allowed to do this where they act like
their partner is off limits when their partner actively engages.
It's like actually yourself. Son has to bring up my father and
his Yeah, for real, dude. Literally. Oh my god. Good times. Good
times. Oh, this person's a loser. Blah blah blah. There's no
There's nothing of that. There's nothing of that. There's literally
nothing of that. Thank you for the super chat.
I don't know where this narrative is coming from that I'm some
sort of snake. What's What What am I doing that's snake? Like,
bro, what have I done? I made some public comments talking some
right.
Okay, that's wonderful. And apparently that makes me a snake.
Where's the evidence of me being a snake? Is
fair how where where am I being a snake exactly? Is it reaching
out privately to people that have got a disagreement that don't
seem to want to talk publicly and saying, "Hey, do you want to
talk about this? We could even talk privately." Is that a being
a snake? I don't understand how that's being a snake. You know,
if anything, the Wait, why the did you gift me 10 subs?
Wholeaning gifted me 10. That was ages ago for I lost a bet.
Yeah.
Only thing that I'm doing is
snake in my community out of content if that ends up happening.
I don't understand. I don't I do not get this idea that I'm suddenly
this untrustworthy individual because I've made some comments
talking some admittedly. Yes. Right.
Comments which I'd be more than happy if wanted to. I could have
on stream. I could we could talk. If only there was some way
for Chud to know that these people might not handle like mild
criticism or even like medium criticism that's like banter and
not really seriously considered. If only there was some way for
him, you know, if there was a canary in the coal mine that might
lead to him to believe that making that comment might lead to
those guys, you know, nexting him in some way. only there was
some way like some example internal victim this guy just crying
any that applies to Tommy too by the way right he's banging on
about I've not spoken to him for 6 months I mean that's a two-way
street thank you for the sub I'm saying or you disagree with
his face right thank you for the five months why not just drop
me a line why don't just drop me a message and say hey I've got
an disagreement or an issue with something that you're saying
and we can talk about it and if you and if you want to speak
privately you don't want to do it in front of an audience but
you're worried about me being a snake Then record it. Well, I
was record I won't even [__] record it if you want.
You can record it. Record it and then release it if you want.
I don't care. I've got nothing to hide. I got literally nothing
to hide. And if you want to have like a disagreement about something,
we can have a disagreement. That's an interesting point. Um I
think these commentary are so brain broken from the group chats
and planning what they say publicly that when somebody says something
publicly, they think it's planned. Yeah. That like because they
are consistently like uh what do you call it? Synchronizing on
messaging, they just assume that's happening in another sphere.
right? they they just can't possibly fathom other people, you
know, sort of having some external rubric that they evaluate
statements or their opinions with and that like even with like
um even with total doing stuff any like there isn't coordination
but like any discussion or anything is also done in public like
spicy chat you can just look in you can just see that's like
where 90% of the discussion is it's
do you think where is the snaking where is the plotting it's
Do you think it's just it's automatically like a negative? Like
if we were good friends, you would want to talk to me privately
first so we can decide what can be said publicly. And if you
just want to talk to me publicly first, I assume you're doing
a gotcha. That is their default position. Yes.
say something negative about
I mean therefore if we have any disagreement or anything like
you need to have free time personal time to dedicate to me.
Yep. Uh and I would say that's probably facilitated by these
group chats, right? Like literally if they have a disagreement,
they do it in these group chats. I think that's the culture they
built up over time. Like they used to have the RFC show, so I'm
guessing in the RFC after show, they'd probably do a more open
thing like this,
I that's what Aiden seemed to claim was like when they did RFC
they used to do this kind of thing and they would criticize and
it was all fine and then at some point I the other thing is is
once you get big enough right like I Tom was there with like
2 million subs I'm sure a lot of them would be like nice to Tom
and wouldn't want to burn that bridge I don't know
so I I think about it at least I don't [__] understand
where this like you know you can say a lot of things about me
right but snake untrustworthy like where Where? What? Where have
I been? I'm trustworthy, bro. I stream 8 hours a day. Everything
I say on stream is recorded. Well, not at the moment cuz I'm
kind of part time this week. Everything I say is recorded. Okay.
Obviously, I do speak to people behind the scenes, right? And
that'll either be, you know, maybe speak, you know, I will say
to people, hey, if you've got a Discord, we could talk about
it privately if you want. You know, it doesn't have to be a public
spectacle. You know, I'm not I'm not looking to snake anyone.
I'm not looking to anyone over. I'm happy to converse and talk
and have a conversation. So, I don't understand where this like
snake allegation is coming from. And like funny that Chud cares
so much. Chud cares way more about being called dishonest than
he does being called like a by Tommy C. I guarantee you like
that's the thing that actually like stings or actually like kind
of annoys him. Cares is what's that?
Sorry. also cares about the
um that what is it the the trans person that he's that turned
out to be 17. That's probably really annoying, right? Some from
like 5 years ago. I know. I'm saying I'm saying no, I'm actually
saying I that was what I was talking about when I said he's called
is like I'm saying I don't think he actually cares about that.
Are we saying Chud is never dishonest? I'm not saying Chud's
never dishonest, but not dishonest enough that he should be called
out by like his professional peers probably. I don't I don't
see him as dishonest. Like dis It would depend on what you mean
by dishonest. Like, oh, he like leaked something or some [__]
I don't know. With the Boax thing, like the Bolex dress thing,
maybe that's some dishonesty, but I just don't see I don't see
him as like naturally dishonest in some way. Not No, I would
see him No, he does come off as like naturally dishonest. It's
like a very dishonesty. I know well enough to maintain my career.
Um, and just like subtly throw shade, right? Oh, sure. If you
want to say like or pull punches, I can avoid talking. I can
avoid complaining directly about this person. I can avoid directly
asking this person to come on stream. Yeah. Okay. There is there
is a little bit there that um like strategic dishonesty. If Tommy
Yeah. If Tommy had a point, okay, it would be this that Chud
walks the line perfectly so that he can constantly say, "Oh,
no. I was just it was just banter, bro. It was just banter."
Right. But he is like throwing those out those to actually people
off.
The complaint would be that he is The complaint is he's walking
the line perfectly. Like let me know when he trips, right? It
is. I mean, I think they're saying that he has tripped. I think
that's what they're saying is he has tripped. Like going after
Nicholas was him tripping.
Well, they tried to say that except now it just looks like Tommy
C would sweep for if it
the Willy he didn't talk his friends. I think the Willy Mack
post shows some amount of like agreement on their side. No. Am
I crazy? Does it say anything? Hold on. Let me pull Let me pull
the This is not it. Sorry. Yeah. No, I think this is uh I don't
think and I mean correct me if anybody thinks I'm wrong on this.
I see this as like this is a group chat opinion getting posted
in public, right? There's like there's like a 25 to 40% chance
that he's trolling and listening. Yeah. This is like gassing
up somebody to make another video. Oh, you think so? Yeah. But
I don't I don't I actually don't know because it's like what
I mean he could be trolling but he like kind of
like a good amount of what Tommy said there, right? Oh man, I
would I wouldn't risk being in a I wouldn't risk being in a group
chat with Aiden and then making this comment and then saying
I was trolling. Okay,
if there if there were logs of me saying this opinion unironically,
I would not I would not make this post and then say I was trolling.
You know what I'm saying? I think probably if you think there's
a 25% chance he's trolling, I don't think you I think I mean
if you had to guess, I feel like you would have made this comment
in private. You really think it's like everything? That's true.
Aiden leaks everything. I don't trust that guy. Shifty. Hey,
maybe it is. Hey, maybe it is just sarcastic. But okay. Well,
if it's sarcastic, then doesn't that mean he's kind of mocking
Tommy?
Uh, it does. That's That's why I don't understand. I feel like
he does. He does like Tommy. Don't know. No. I It's so easily
explicable just by who makes more money, who's like the better
content creator, who would you rather maintain a bridge with,
right? That's like the easiest way to explain it, I think, is
you say this is sarcasm. You do this as sarcasm, mocking Tommy
because you're ready to just like burn Tommy to move on to Chud.
You'd rather have Chud as your boomer of the group now,
right? Like that that to me makes perfect sense. I would expect
that actually.
Is Tommy not that big of a creator? I don't really know. Uh he
was he used to be. Tommy's totally in the sucks. Tread is a bigger
creator by far. But yeah, orders of magnitude bigger. Six times.
Yeah. Six or seven times bigger. Maybe more.
Uh, wire rope. I'm familiar with the uh what is that? Halfbaked.
Is that the halfbaked podcast or something?
Is that what it's called?
The Nick the Nick Tom podcast. Yeah. Is Willie bigger or smaller
than these
Please. Um,
Willie is bigger than Chud. I mean, in terms of people's numbers.
Okay. Who do you think makes more money? Not a live
Yeah, I would say I'd say Chud definitely makes way more money.
Just probably not more money. Yeah, but but Willie is probably
more famous, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'd say now that I'm looking at
it, say Willie makes 10K a month. Yeah. Yeah, but Willie also
puts in like no hours, so he makes that money off of like like
per hour Willie gets paid like way more than other people, right?
He does normal things like touching grass and I don't know. I
don't know, man.
No, the last time I heard that he was he went on to tweet about
Jtock for like four days in a row on Twitter.
Touching grass. You can do that and touch grass. Why wouldn't
you be able to touch grass? Anyway, sorry. Uh, I think now that
now that somebody pointed out the sarcasm thing. Yeah, never
mind. Cuz I that's my whole thought is if Chud just opens the
door to say like, "Oh, we'll put this under the bridge and we
can maintain this and all you guys have to do is disavow Tommy."
They'll just disavow Tommy. They'll just put Tommy out to pasture,
right? Tommy's basically put himself out to pasture. There's
nothing to be gained there. I think you can look at it mostly
on that scale. So loud.
Uh, yeah. I think you can look at things with that like uh rubric
and you'll just be correct like 95% of the time. I don't know.
I'm I'm putting that out there to see if there's any disagreement
in the chat or in here. But I think that's probably correct.
Nick is loyal to Tommy. Okay. I don't I I don't
know. I understand that Nick has always been loyal to Tommy,
but Tommy went out on a limb here and basically said, "Everybody
hates you, Chud. I know everybody hates you from these group
chats. And now Nick has to decide whether he's going to look
like the Yeah. the mean girls like catty in the background who
talks about Chut and says he'll never go on his stream anymore
or if he wants to kind of like just go no. This old man's like
kind of losing it. Oh, I wish I could. Would anybody bet me that
Nick will either not comment or take Chud's side? Nick won't
comment. I think Nick hates Queman and you JT talk enough to
severize. People claim that he doesn't hate Queman, but then
I don't understand why he hates me. I don't understand why you
would hate me if he doesn't hate Queman. Very confusing. I'm
a diva. I'm not I don't make it by myself all the time. Uh yeah,
you do. What are you talking about? True. You literally watch
your If you're in a content piece, you'll watch it five times.
What do you mean you're not a diva? Shut the up. Guy thinks he
could just come on here and say literally anything. Like nobody's
watching. It's wild. I'm not a diva. Yeah, I watched that piece
of Stardust content like four times cuz you mentioned me. Yeah,
of course I did. I'm right. Of course I did. I'm right. It just
feels like a copout of like not wanting to talk to me for some
reason. I don't know why exactly. And acting like it's because
I'm a snake.
Okay, that's wonderful. How do I make more? Show me where I've
been a snake people. Thank you for the super chats. I mean, is
it not Yeah. Is it not a bit like, you know, what are you going
to do about this chological thing? We'll get to the groom stuff
as well. We'll get to the groom stuff, too. But uh but yeah,
you know, and I do think about me Oh my god. about these things
because I do the reason it's kind of frustrating that I'm getting
called a snake is because I do think about this stuff, right?
And obviously I speak to like a multi YouTubers don't need to
keep a bridge. Only streamers do that. Uh, sure. Let's check
out Bobax's channel. What's a What's the Bob's channel? Is it
Is it That's not because he didn't keep a bridge. That's not
because he didn't keep a bridge. You think it's cuz he slacked
on his content? You think even if he was fighting with Doro,
he would have because he is he stopped doing his content. He's
doing a content model that was already losing traction that that
just isn't that popular anymore. Uh people get like their little
bite-sized internet drama stuff from Tik Tok now. Um Instagram
reels or whatever the no one's going watch video of tweets. Uh
that's why internet versus even though it does the exact same
thing but better uh still does not hit the heights of of Bob's
old stuff because people don't watch that content anymore. So
Bob didn't evolve in any way and did a stale content model that
he then slacked on. Uh so that's just like a totally losing strategy
no matter what bridges you've got. Yeah, sure.
Sure. People and at times I may end up speaking to people that
I'm friends with or friendly with. Okay. And I try and be quite
diligent in not like talking because the last thing I want is
to like talk behind someone's back and then that get publicized
and like
uh the other thing that makes this a little interesting to me
is I do think there is the other element of like okay if you're
going to call actually now that I'm going to get about it now
that I want to try to steal man the other side of this there
is something to the whole why did you why did you just say that
about Nicholas I totally disavow that that totally unhinged comment
that I read out I totally disavow there is that hole, right?
Playing into that, which is funny, totally. But I could see I
could see if he did that to Nicholas or if he was doing that
to like, you know, Tommy or some other people, how they would
take that they could take that the wrong way. That I would say
is 100% banter. But um like especially when the communities like
actually hate these people like it's not like the person writing
the comment is bantering, right? Chud's bantering when he goes,
"Oh, I totally disavow that. That's a crazy comment." The big
problem is that the community over on sort of this side, not
necessarily your side, but but Ch's side, my side, it is really
funny and their community is really not. It's all like a bunch
of like unfunny annoying hags and
people whereas like we have like people like uh you know Deep
Armor and Stylo who are like really funny and so you have to
read those comments off because they are really funny. Uh but
none of their communities are contributing anything so they don't
really have an equivalent.
Yeah. Sure, Sure. Context on this commentary war. Chud Logic
is uh he's normally lazier chatters. Uh I think Debraama's funny,
but he's not really uh I don't know if he's um I don't know what
community that How do I pull out say something so I can look
at your chat logs? You you wouldn't get a humor. It's fine. Yeah.
You say I'm the only funny female. So what? You're funny. You're
funny in a different way. Okay. Droma is funny because he can
code anti-semitism in a way that I only only I understand. That's
why he's funny.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that's Listen, you're speaking you're speaking like in
code under the surface is very good times. What is this? I got
link something. Oh, they're racist. Funny. Also, the only reason
basically basically all of them are racist funny. Also, the only
reason I'm talking about this is because there's like barely
anything happening at the moment. The drama ecosystem is as dry
as the Sahara. Unless you're willing to do the 20th stream sucking
off Ethan Klein. Yes, I'm talking about you, Nicholas Dioro.
Okay. Unless you're willing to do the 20th stream going, "Oh,
isn't Ethan correct about everything?" And the song's totally
wrong. Unless you're willing to do that, it's dry as the Sahara
out there, bro. Yeah, that is
Is that really where you just end everything? Right there. No,
trust me, Cherry. This guy's just a very, very niche racist.
Also, wait, Queen, do you have the Do you have the Aerodyite
Something crazy.
Can I show it on stream? What is it? I don't know if you want
to. What happened? Now I have to see. What is it?
Father, date.
Uh, no. Oh, that's not funny. That is funny.
Send it to you. I've got mute. Jesus. Okay. All right. What?
You want to explain why that's funny?
Not on stream. No. That's too crazy. Holy [__]
Okay. All right. I think he's funny. All right. Well, Deeperama
is funny most of the time. God, don't do that. Well, unfortunately
I got to do it to you this time. This one time I got to do it
to you guys. All right. It's uh What the [__] are
we doing here? Oh, Ry sent me this. It said this is the context.
We all know the context, by the way. I didn't need to watch this.
Cherry was aware. Everyone was aware. But and I look like a snake.
But it just seems like now the snakiness is just like, "Oh, he's
a snake." Quum was laughing. It's racist. Well, yeah. It's a
Deeper Rama post. I told you Deeper is funny because he's anti-Semitic
and Queen is a self-hating Jew. Of course, that's what he's laughing
at. He's a snake because he might betray Nicholas at some point
in the future because he talks some on stream. I mean, he might
watch a video that's critical of Nicholas and say it's good.
I mean, it's ridiculous, bro. It's ridiculous. I think I just
got it.
That's [__] long. I'm sorry about something as well.
Right. There is now a tendency to not want to like have conversations
on stream about stuff. I somewhat understand it, right? And I've
been gracious for people that don't want to have a conversation
on on my stream because I think yeah, our community could be
really irritating. Wonderful. But how about aggressive and I
get that. Thank you for the super chat. Thank you. So, you know,
I'm not saying like, you know, doing the debate, bro.
Capitalizing the memes. Secret memes go in the older chat. Oh,
maybe. Could be. Could be of like you've got to talk to me on
stream that you must you must talk to me, right? Okay, that's
wonderful. But how do I make money? Thank you for the super chat,
guys. But it's I spoke to Tectton a couple of weeks ago, right?
And that was kind of like a mid-con conversation because he was
like being extremely friendly and kind of showed his belly. But
if like I I can have a conversation with Teone about some stupid
disagreement, surely we can have a chat on the stream about some
other disagreement. Not that we have to, by the way. No one has
to come on my stream. I'm not saying that anyone's got to come
on my stream. What I'm more talking about as well is it's not
just like not I mean if you don't want to have a combo, that's
fine. I I get that. I I do somewhat get not wanting to just approve
of nothing. come on a stream and hash out some disagreement that
you've got for whatever reason, right? But we've now got this
like bizarre avoidance of having a conversation to the point
where like I I didn't really follow it that closely because I'm
a bit checked out of the camera and stuff, but I did see that
it was like Papa Gut was reacting. But how do I make money off
depressed people? People will always betray America. I've not
betrayed anyone, but thank you for the $5. It was like Peppa
Gut was reacting to Quan whilst I'm sorry.
Peppa Peppa Gut.
He's just being British. Whilst
Wait, waiting. Do you say it like that, Agreement? Papa gut.
No, he doesn't. No, no, no, no, no, he doesn't. I've heard him
say it a thousand times. He doesn't say it that way. He just
said it.
I've heard him say papa gut like a thousand times. Papa gut.
Papa Gut. I don't know. Uh yeah. Yeah. Papa Gut was watching.
Oh, are you saying his dad just said it that way, so now he's
got it? Yeah, he was just he was just mirroring skinw walking.
And at that point, are you just not going to talk to the guy?
Are you just not going to have a combo agreement? Like why why
is this bizarre
reaction when there's an offer on the table to talk? It doesn't
make any sense to me. Just have a conversation, bro. And again,
Queman is very irritating and I totally understand if you don't
want to like have a combo with Quean say just out proper of nothing.
Queman says some I've been saying this and nobody is picking
it up but Chud's picking up so it's like derange about you on
streaming [__] but it's the fact that you're reacting
to his content like you're talking about you're watching him
react to you but having a conversation is too much. Okay that's
wonderful but how do I make it just doesn't make any sense to
me. My gut makes my skin crawl bad or sick guy. Thank the super
chat. It's like, you know, when Essence of Thought was in chat
the other day, right? I would have happily brought Essence of
Thought on to talk about the stuff, right? If Inuendo Studios,
there was an opportunity. Okay, that's wonderful. But how do
I make money people chat? It's not that deep. Chad was tired
of his skinny girlfriend and wanted that big booty and Dioro.
Now he feels and thank you for the super chuds. Uh, okay. Somebody's
going to make that image, by the way, of Chud with
uh and boy Nicholas.
Yeah, somebody's going to make that now. That is being made by
somebody. Somebody will make that.
And just in case they weren't going to, I'm just going to keep
saying somebody will make that until it eventually happens. You
know, if if like somehow you studios got wind of my coverage
and you wanted to talk, that's like content, bro. That's like
Yes. Let's about your avoid the tax, you know? That's that's
a good opportunity. It's just generally speaking and you know
obviously with techone it did turn out differently but generally
when you're like talking about someone it tends to be like a
bigger creator that you don't really have any chance to talk
to anyway because they're we get a donut. No, I'm not that invested.
I'm saying it will get made. I know some twisted people watch
kick late night. Okay. The ones that tend to get involved in
the more interesting drama. You know
why?
Was it like counterpoints his stomach? That'd be pretty funny.
Yeah. Harry drew it earlier after Dagle.
He's reacting to his He's reacting to him reacting to him and
he just doesn't want to have a conversation. Sorry, Pepsi. We
should just say Pepsi to be honest with you until he eventually
changes it back. It's uh Okay.
That's [__] up, you know. And and Oh, it's um it's
like I think we I don't want to do the No, he's just a commentary
person, but he's insane. He went on a He's not a commentary person.
He's a spicy chat
Really? No, I knew who you were talking about. I just wanted
to I just wanted to it. Oh, I see. You know, it's like it's just
bizarre. And whilst it isn't quite the same thing with the Tommy
C thing and I don't know whether just wanted me to react to the
video cuz then they've got content for their stream. Um, you
know, Tommy C is talking about things that I've said on stream
and it's fine. I don't mind him talking and saying his piece
about it. Whatever. Say what you want to say. But then he's like,
"Oh, you can you can respond how you want on stream." dream.
It's like, well, why not have a combo? Why not oil combo?
Ew. You know what? That's a solid effort. That's a way better
effort than I thought was going to go into that. What do you
mean that's a solid effort? There's literally a tool to color
inside. It's a bucket. You just you click the button and there's
it's supposed to be filled with color. Well, he's only just coloring
now. Yeah. He didn't do the full coloring clearly. I think it's
really important to tell people when they suck at art. expression
on his face is just very funny. It's like very dreading. Anyway,
anyway, not for three Somebody paid $350 for that. Apparently,
somebody paid 300.
What? What's that? There's probably multiple people chipped in,
but yeah. Yeah, I would imagine. Yeah.
Why don't you know, clearly you've got some issues with me. Why
not just hash it out in a combo on stream or even off stream,
which I, you know, I borrowed it on stream. We could do it off
stream and you can record it if you want. You think I'm going
to snake you in some way? You know, why is this aversion to ever
having a conversation? You know, when when it's like you're engaging
with the person in some way that you've got a disagreement with,
you know? I just don't understand it. It's just it's just this
weird, you know, is is it like people don't want to don't want
to look bad? You're worried that like you might make some bad
arguments or something? I don't know, dude. Like, what does it
matter at the end of the day? It's online debate. You know, I've
had online debates that I've done badly at and you know, it's
forgotten in a week and no one cares. trying to think of like
the analogy that works for the ADL thing. It's kind of to me
like uh basically people say like, "Well, I didn't say I supported
the ADL." But it's sort of like um you know how a bunch of Republicans
and like uh libertarian types were like super celebrating when
January 6th was going on and then the next day they're like,
"Oh, that was disgusting. That I don't like that at all." That's
the same feeling I get from the people who are like, "No, no,
no.
in any other situation. You you can recognize when someone is
making every single argument up to the line, stopping at the
line and not really giving you a conclusion either way. Like
it's not like people are saying, "Oh, I think it's bad intimate."
But deplatforming is never just like, you know, whatever. They're
not doing that. They're walking you up to the line thing. I don't
know. I don't know.
It's like, well, at that point, everyone knows what's going on
here. Like it's to play the was deniability game.
Man, I just I think it's like you can't sit there and cheer when
people I I think I think this is January 6th thing to me. Like
you cheer as people enter the like the capital building. You're
like, "Oh, 1776. This is so awesome." And then a week later you're
like, "No, this is an embarrassment." You're like, "No, no, no.
I would never support the ADL. I don't believe in the ADL at
all." And then you like go back and watch their streams when
like the ADL talks at Twitch and all of the people get banned
and they're like that's so awesome. Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
Yeah. It's it's embarrassing that they then they go, "No, no,
no. I have nothing to do the ADL. They disgust me. Those those
insurrectionists everyone moves on and that's that. Weird. But
yeah, it's like just this bizarre, you know, aversion to having
a combo. Um which, you know, again, just to be clear, you don't
have to have a conversation with any that comes along and talks
about you, right? That's especially if you're like a larger creator
that becomes very difficult to facilitate. But if you're watching
someone react to you and talking like about them, why not talk
to them then? Clearly, you want to engage with the arguments
they're making because you're watching them react to you, but
you don't want to talk to them for some reason. Is it fair? It's
uh it's literally
and I could I don't know if Papa Gut's like familiar with you.
I could understand why somebody wouldn't want to talk to you
directly. you're uh you're very good in a like on the-fly conversation,
right? And Papa Gut probably isn't. Papa Gut's probably like
an actual. So, I could see why he wouldn't like he would feel
like he could engage with you slowly, but like in a real time
conversation where he's kind of getting where he might get railroaded
down some path he's not ready for. I think he doesn't want to
do that. Not that that's necessarily okay if he's going to like
react to your [__] and talk a bunch of and call you
anti-semitic. I think it's pretty up to call somebody anti-semitic
and refuse to talk to them. But that's what I think. Rabbi Rabbi
Gut needs to get on my stream right now. Rabbi Rabbi Gut, debate
me.
Uh-huh. I disavow that, by the way. That's open anti-semitism.
He's He's actually calling for to die right now. Do you know
that you're doing that? How many Okay. How many have to die?
You don't want to look bad. Is it like optics? I don't know.
Happy guy. Uh
uh. No. He he uh didn't know his father and his father was the
ones who was patrineal descent and so it's completely fake and
but he claims it anyway. Does that mean that like Israel is kind
of sacriiggious by doing birthright that they're not confirming
the matrinal lines that like kind of
sacri there are like you know obviously sects of Judaism or whatever
that that fine with patrol but if you're going by the strictest
definition I think honestly the most dominant one I believe um
then yeah is matrinal
he hooked up with his best friend to get with a woman and found
out he's 100% % straight. We kissed in front of all these women
like screaming and howling. They were ferocious. It felt like
nothing. My his lips were so chapped. My stubble on his felt
dot dot dot. The first time I kissed a dude, it was the same
way.
Yeah. What? Except this is just like a total lie from TTO because
we know that he was looking at Fenboy.
Uh yeah, but like the stubble rubbing that's Yeah, but Yeah.
But no, I'm saying the part that he's 100% straight. He doesn't
He's not 100%. Oh, yeah. He's not 100% gay.
Yeah, sure. Yeah, sure. What What is Why would When would Asmin
Gold have done this?
I I feel like it's just like they keep getting called right wings,
so they pretend to be gay or something. Oh, dude, dude, dude,
dude, dude, dude. No, no, no, no, no. Somebody actually made
a fantastic post on my subreddit today. Uh, sorry. Fantastic.
It's like a good post on my subreddit today. Asmin Gold Tech.
this one. R/ Gold switching from bigots to LGBT allies whenever
the topic shifts to Muslims. This is like 100% accurate, right?
Like literally, they will go from like absolutely like being
disgusted by trans people to like, no, no, no. If they threw
that trans person, that trans person I said should never get
the healthcare they want. Um, if they threw that person off a
building, I would be very cross right now. Okay. That would be
really up. Okay. Okay, dude. Sure. Sure. Anyway, back to Chud.
Very, very odd. Very odd behavior, you
Um, that's great timing where sorry with the gay kids. Yeah,
I mean, you know, very odd behavior. If he's got like these big
issues with me and he wants to hash it out, I'm I'm happy to
talk to him in whatever format he's most comfortable with, you
know. But, um, it seems like
really is a debate PDF file and a Hassan gogobbler. He is a low
IQ [__] who thinks that he knows better than he does.
Mihawk, call in anytime. disc.gg/queenman. GG/ Queenman.
Although there were some comments criticism,
I'm going to go. It seems like he's just furious about, right?
Like the amount of times that Queenman got mentioned in a segment
that was ostensibly about me is absurd. Even going as far back,
okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make money off depressed
people? Ethan and Hassan has been a vicious curse upon this space.
Principles have been tossed out and spines are now missing. Thank
you, your truth, king. Thank you for the super chats. He was
complaining about that time that he was on stream and Queman
came on, right? And apparently I like apologized after or something
like that, right? Do you know how long ago that was? I had to
go back and check because I was like that what year ago talking
about that, right? Around about a year ago. It was like it was
uploaded to my channel like 27th of June 2024. It was like a
year ago. Why he still he's still talking about that? He's still
talking about the year ago when Creman came on and you know they're
the debate. I can't I can't even remember what it was about.
I just remember Tommy calling Quman a bread tuber and uh yeah,
you know, I understand like you know I get Tommy C hating Queman,
right? Quan went ballistic over Tommy C and was doing endless
streams about him calling him like a
scenar. And off the back of some of it because there was a little
bit of drama I think I watched a bit of I wouldn't say endless.
revelations to do with his wife or something like that, right?
And then towards the end of it, I was just a bit like a people
watch that, you know, I don't think I was like particularly harsh
on Tommy if I recall correctly. And I'm pretty sure that at the
time I said that some of it was a bit excessive, you know, but
it feels like Tommy wanted me to like intervene in some way like,
you know, as if as if Queen is some sort of bastard extension
of my body, my fleshy mass. Queen's little face is in my chest
that oh, oh, I'm trying to hate people. Oh mate, I'm a self-hating.
It's like, bro, we can clip that. I think we can clip that. Oh,
I'm going to hate people. Oh, mate, I'm a self-hating. It's like,
bro, what where are the hand movements coming from? I feel like
those those hand movements in
handic, you know, he does like similar hand movements, right?
the it's like bro he's not me like I'm not Queanman if you can't
tell we look quite different different body mass okay just leave
it at that I'm not queen I don't necessarily agree with everything
that says and unless queen is like doxing someone or or doing
something that is like completely and utterly objectionable what
am I supposed to [__] do likeman's his own man doing
his own content he's got his own dramas going on you know he's
got his own happening now like that's up to I'm not I'm not literally
like yes I know the father meme is there I'm not literally Quman's
father you know I'm not I'm not responsible for what he does
like queen can do what queen wants to do judge me by my opinions
and what I say about things you know rather than oh queen this
and queen that you know it's so stupid yeah what is it um after
total recall queen Tommy
Tommy dude it comes across like what are you going to do about
this and the thing is look I get it I listen to Creamman. I tend
to learn alert now because I don't want to be seen in Jack because
people are really annoying about it. But, you know, can be very
abrasive and obnoxious. You know, I don't necessarily agree with
everything says. Obviously, we've obviously got different takes
on different things. But like, isn't it valuable to have someone
that's got like a different perspective from like the other people
that are in the space? I don't know, dude. I think it's kind
of nice to have someone that's got a different perspective on
it that tends to be even if you disagree with it, fairly well
reasoned and fairly well. Oh, Sty is trying to rebuild the bridge
with Queenman. You're mahawk.
Does Mahawk guy say? What did he What did he say? King at King
Style. Dude, Chud is funny on purpose. Just look at most of Queenman
thumbnails and worse his nega channel. Whoa.
That tends to be even if you disagree with fairly well reasoned
and fairly well thought out, you know. Like I think it's pretty
decent to have someone there that's going to give a different
take a different perspective. You know, Chad, it's just that
you praise him and raid him so people automatically associate
with him with you. That's fine. Well, then say, okay, if that's
your well then say that's your problem. I don't like the fact
that Chud supports Creamman because I don't like him. There's
your problem then. But that's not what the problem is stated
is. It's that, you know, this ill illusion to this idea that
I'm somehow responsible for what Creman is doing. And with that
in mind as well, right, I said that some of that gay that was
happening was too much. I said the gay stuff was too much. I
said this is stupid. I don't think I was like, you know, I made
a couple of memes about it. Okay, sure. I Yeah, but I wasn't
like supporting it. And I, you know, saw that there's all this
being talked about Tommy C. I just didn't really pay much attention
to it. But what am I supposed to do intervene? I don't understand.
Like what is it you want me to do if someone that is tangentially
related to me and from my community is making content on you?
Like what what am I supposed to do? Am I supposed to intervene?
Am I supposed to step in and be like, "Creman, it's your speaking.
Quan, get to your room now. You You've been talking about people
I like again." I do I do feel like Chud's intervention is saying
like, "Don't do that." Or he It's literally him saying like,
"You went too far." Like he literally says it right. That's the
intervention. He's like, "I think Queen went too far with this.
I I think queen this gay op went too far. He is like intervening.
Yeah, it wasn't gay. He used all the time anyway. It wasn't gay
up. It was scop. But listen. Okay. All
It's so stupid, bro. It's so stupid. And you know, it seems like
from my perspective, and obviously I've seen people in chat pointing
this out, it seems like his biggest issues with me are that I
talk some about Nicholas in the course of my rant the other day
because Tommy is constantly throwing himself in front of Nicholas
whenever someone criticizes him. Um, and my criticism wasn't
even that crazy, I don't think. And some issues of Creman that
is being put on my doorstep as if it was my problem to deal with,
you know. I went back and looked at our messages back from December
and I don't want to get into the business of leaking messages,
you know, cuz funnily enough, I'm not actually a snake, okay?
So, I'm not looking to leak anything, right? I'm not interested
in doing that, but he's talking about slasher thing. Do you know
the last message I sent to Tommy Seawward? But here are the last
messages we talked about back in December of last year. I'm not
I'm not a jank, but here's the last thing we talked about. I'm
not in the business of legging DMs, but I do this all the time,
but I'm not really I don't really have a like to stand on here.
I'm just saying something you got to say. This like literally
I'm pretty sure literally the last thing I said to him was, "Oh,
I looked at the slasher stuff and it was overblown. Depressed
people, you know, I talked about it on stream. Let me know if
you got any issues with what I said." That was what I said to
him. Oh, you bring up this slasher thing when the last thing
I said to him, the last thing I said to him was I think it was
overblown,
you know. So, I don't understand it. Well, that's now point of
issue of intention. Stupid off depressed people. Thank you for
the super chats. It's just, you know, I don't know. It's just
uh just just feels like you know um I've made some some criticism
he doesn't like. Wonderful. But how do I make money off press
people? King Rainbow became a member. King Rainbow celebrates
21 months of membership bugman battle.
It feels like I've you know made some made some criticisms that
he doesn't like and you know he's annoyed about how some of the
with him that tangentially or more direct. Darius is losing it.
I don't care. Darius just fakes that because you guys you just
roll in. It's fine. you can go watch. I don't care to me anyone.
Also, I've been streaming for like eight hours, so I'm probably
go to sleep right away. Have this kind of like, you know, all
these comments about it.
But like I say, you know, that's my I guess response to what
he was talking about and if he wants to talk further, um, you
know, I'm not getting into this like, you know, react to me then
I'll react to you, etc. We can just have a conversation. We can
just have a [__] conversation about it, you know,
and I can explain all my points. I don't know if you watch the
rest of it. Oh, yeah. No, I'm watching the rest of it right now.
I I do want to get this whole segment. I think I watched I already
watched like quite a bit of this. I think this is around the
time where I I haven't actually watched than when I'm having
rage on stream and we can see what we what we think, you know.
I mean, that's how it used to be done. And um the other thing
as well the Okay, it's not the public guy doesn't want to talk
to he doesn't want to be pushed on his opinions. It's way easier
to talk over video than a personal conversation. Well, the thing
is is like, you know, I know that there's some people out there
that are like very deranged and will just like go gets at you
and it's not really worth getting into with them. Um, but I just
generally wouldn't talk about their content then and then it's
not a problem, you know? I think I think if you're going to talk
about someone's content, I think you need to be ready to have
a conversation if they then want to have a conversation. I think
that's a pretty reasonable standard to have. Like you don't you
don't have to like speak to any that comes up that is knocking
on your door and going like I made I made extreme talking about
you to three viewers. Talk to me now. That's silly and obviously
it's not it's not sustainable to do that especially if you're
like a bigger content creator. But if you're like talking about
someone's takes and stuff like that, like why not have a combo?
It's absurd. Papa Gut was blindsided by the Queenman [__]
What was he blindsided by? He called He called the guy anti-Semitic.
You think you just throw out that allegation willy-nilly? Yeah,
sure. Me, me, me, techie, I tell you what, me, techie, Nick,
and Tommy C need to squ up in Fortnite and get this all squared
away. That's what we need to do. I'm not watching the video.
I've already said I'm not watching the video. You can go watch
it. Don't brigade. Don't even shoot the comments if you want
to go and see all of his takes. Exactly. Oh, he said that first.
No, I think Queen watched something for Papa Gut and said he
was a and then Papa Gut reacted and called him anti-Semitic.
Right.
I think that's how it went. Go and watch it. Let me know if you
got misop.
But I think I pretty fairly laid out, you know, the rough strokes
of what he was saying and I've tried to express my issues in
a calm fashion in the slight heated heated moments of time. But
you know the thing is what did he say first? Only a uh probably
not. I would imagine he went into more depth. Often does. What
did you say about Papa Gut?
Um, you said he's a loser who only has like 600 viewers after
10 years.
Yeah. He's a total fat,
stagnant loser who has got nowhere in his expensive career. Okay.
Surrounded by Funko Pops. Big Ethan Klein for free Teddy Fresh
clothing.
Um, and I went through some of his coverage of the Cameron stuff
and then some of his coverage of Hassan and uh, yeah, he was
just saying like that Hassan was saying the opposite of what
he was saying at every time at every like point. Um, yeah, sure.
Incapable of doing anything. Is that not true? I mean, hold on.
Full of hell. Are you going to extend this same thing to Kelly
Jean when she calls certain people certain words and you're going
to go, well, is that not true? I feel I don't remember your position
on Kelly Jean calling certain people, but I seem to remember.
Would you Which side of that were you on? Yeah, I'll talk to
him, too. He's good faith. I mean, unfortunately, if he was really
bad faith, it should be very easy for you to go analyze the stream
and point out exactly where he's being bad faith and why he's
wrong, right? Did Papa Gut do that effectively? No. Papa Got
refused to engage with literally anything I said. He just did
they like uh sarcastically agree with everything and then you
know act incredulous. What we say does everything right? Yeah.
Could never criticize. He didn't he literally didn't even dare
touch the Hassan stuff. He stopped the moment he got there. Based
something can be true and mean to say. Sure. Full of hell. I
agree with you. I'm not looking to like burn bridges or have
like a crash out drama with someone over the Ethan Assange. a
drama that I'm largely checked out of and not interested in talking
about because I've talked about it for so long. Why do I want
to snake someone over that? Oh, I don't think you're I don't
think you're criticizing Ethan enough, so I'm gonna snake you.
I don't care much about it, dude. I just got you know, I expressed
some of my concerns in a frustrated fashion on stream. That was
enough for me to get out there and then I've moved on. I'm not
looking to get back into all of my Oh, well, I think you said
I don't really care about that much. So, I'm Does Chad wear makeup?
Yeah, but it's just like a basic foundation. It's not like a
lot of It's not like women's makeup. It's just like a basic foundation.
Definitely not looking bridges and me making like some comments
towards Big Nick and Connor, right? Like that to me isn't enough
to like nuke a bridge that we've got. Like if there really is
some underlying issues, happy to have a conference in whatever
um you know way suits them or whatever if they want to. It's
the nickel. I'm not saying anyone needs to talk to me, but that
shouldn't be enough to like end a relationship or something,
right?
when it's just you largely where it's like a quarter fine rage
and a third a third a third Finny rage and a third serious right
why would that be enough to to end it you know I'm sure you know
I'm sure that Nicholas was a bit a bit annoyed like talk some
about him right I'm sure he's a bit annoyed about that fine totally
fine if he wants to be annoyed about it right but I don't think
we've got like you know it's like Tommy's more upset than Nick
is about what's happened do you know what I mean it's bizarre
it's like you know as far as I understand I don't think there's
this big crash out bridge explosion between me and Nicholas.
And would you know what else it feels like as well? It feels
a little bit like I'm I'm almost like feel like I'm getting pulled
into having some commentary Civil War drama. I'm I'm not even
that that involved in like there's this battle happening and
I'm not even fighting in the fight. I'm just like doing my own
thing over here, you know? Yes, I made some comments on
stream. Yes, I talk some. Sure. But is that really enough? I
mean, you know, we're all lads here, aren't we? We're all bloody
lads. Have a bit of bit of banter. Bit of disagreement. Bit of
friendly disagreement. Stuff like that.
What? Queen, if you ever disagree with me on stream, that's it.
Bridges burned. Okay. You [__] up. It's like seriously,
imagine if Tommy C standard was applied to either my relationship
with you or or Ch or anything. Like it' be like over literally
a month in. It's like actually so bor. It's like, no offense,
it's just really nice to have somebody who will like listen to
your opinion and think of how to disagree with you because that's
more entertaining than just sitting there and nodding along and
clapping like, yeah, yeah, I'm going to listen to the thing you
said and try to figure out where you might be wrong and then
we have a conversation about it. It's like just a more enter
I don't know. I'd be so bored. Maybe that's the difference between
like, well, no, Tommy C is a streamer. I was going to say maybe
that's a big difference between streamers and YouTubers or something.
If you're not all lads, Mr. All's co-hosts have been like pure
yesmen or like his like I don't knows that he has on his
female dressing.
I uh Okay.
Dressing. Okay. Yeah. Oh, I thought I thought you were saying
trans people. Female dressing, but you mean female dressing as
in dressing over the Yeah. Like just just like Yeah. making it
more appealing to some like kind of out of out of touch boomer.
Um,
you seem like a loser if there's a woman around, right? I mean,
you probably know this. Well, I was just going to say, you know,
I I agree that the best thing to do with co-hosts. All of my
co- hosts are basically yes men. They just tell me I'm correct
on everything I say. That's what I try to find. Anyway, odd.
Why is it such a deal breaker? Why does it make me a snake? Why
does it make me a snake, dude?
Why does it make me a snake? I had a whole bunch of male co-hosts
at one point. They just they're not around anymore. I don't know
where they all went up, dude. Thank you for the prime sub. True.
That's what I'll off. Look at this autistic freak. Nick and Tommy
C are just mad that spicy chat hate them. Hold on. We got a Smagle
Smagle sighting. Uh
I mean that I mean he's not wrong, is he? He's actually he's
saying off Smaggle, but
true. Wait, wait, wait, wait. No, he said true. That's why when
you read a donation, you say, "I don't want to talk about this.
Thanks for the money, though." What I reply to, I'm not
Uh, let's go back. Oh, that's the Ethan stuff. Cuz he cuz he
said, "I talk about you, Nicholas. You're already saying you
don't have to sound off."
About that, Chudlo Logic. This guy is a total Nicholas always
defends you on his streams. Every time I watch his recent streams,
he always liked you. Uh-huh.
Someone likes you. You can't criticize them. Do you think Do
you think Nicholas was just looking the other way? We'll find
out. I guess we'll find out at some point. Maybe
Why does it make a mistake? Thank you for the prime sub.
I backed it up trying to see where Smaggle is saying this. True.
That's what I'll off. Look at this autistic freak to defend his
daddy. You can get as well, mate. You too. True. That's why when
you read a donation, you just say, "I don't want to talk about
it. Thanks for the money though. I'm out.
Okay, you're going to sit. You're going to do a mocking voice
and you don't do a mocking lisp. Is wrong with this
guy, dude? What? There's no way Chud could be could ever be a
snake. His mouth is way too small. Yeah, sure. Sure. I just It
took me. The moment took me. Okay. And I decided to talk some
Are we really saying that me having a bit of a spury crash out
on stream talking some [__] about other people is
enough to end relationship? Why you saying it's a crash out?
It's like a spy crush. It's a It's not that deep, man. Why does
everyone need complete cow towing? Is that what you think's going
on here? Just complete cowtowing.
It was just cow town. Saying it was a spurgey crash out. It was
cowtowing. It wasn't a spury crash out. It was just like you
had a legitimate complaint, but in the moment you just like expressed
in like an aggressive way. It's like who cares? Like that's what
people want to see on live streams. That's what that's what you're
meant to do to entertain people. It's like one of those things
is I don't know this might be what do you call it? This might
be something like is your friend the person who won't tell you
that there's something in your teeth or that your like breath
stinks or some [__] or is the friend the person who
will be like no your breath smells like go brush your teeth or
something. Right? Like you kind of want your friends to be the
people who are like going to say, "Okay, you have something wrong
with you. Here's what it is." And I'm going to make a joke about
it so we can kind of pretend that I'm not making this criticism.
And then we can move forward like as friends, right? That's what
I think Chud's doing when he makes that comment is he's basically,
"Nicholas, you kind of it up right now, just so you know." But
he's doing it in a way that he can kind of plausibly deny later,
right? Like I don't know. Yeah, possibly. I don't know. Well,
yeah. Like I think it's a real criticism, right? Like I don't
think he says that if he doesn't believe that's true. You know
what I'm saying? Like it's not that he's crashing out. It's not
just that he's making a joke and crashing out. I don't I think
if he thinks that's not true, he holds his tongue there, right?
That's my personal opinion. Yes, Jtock, but Nick is a fat. So
is Tommy, so they think he's attacking them. Uh,
sure. Listen, some people are sensitive. Okay. And I think no
matter what, like even you get that comment about like something
being in your teeth or like I don't know, you get like breath
or something. I'm trying to think of like ones I've heard there
something in your teeth. Like it's basically like you can feel
like, oh, is that like a criticism of me? And it's like, no,
just do better. That's all you got to do. I don't know. Most
of the time I hear Chud criticize me, I'm like, I I think there's
something to it. And I try not to, you know, only think of it
as um what do you call it? I try not to only think of it as like
a like a slight or something because then what's the point of
him making a criticism if you just take it as a slight like actually
if you if you believe it's true or if it actually affects you
I don't know you can like integrate that and make yourself better
in some way feels kind of pointless right to just take it as
a slight and decide I don't know I don't know what are we probably
just overanalyzing this massively cuz um I'm at the end of the
stream doing here bro what are we doing here bro what is going
on. I Okay, seriously to anyone that you know to all the to all
to Queman JTO all the that are going to fun what I what wait
just wait just wait the next stream off the back of this little
rant. Okay to you people in chat okay you in the last 30 minutes
of my stream and I'm half asleep anyone who doesn't like me okay
I can't remember what I was going to say now I
say I thought too much about all the people that are going to
be watching this later But um but yeah, I don't know, dude. It's
it's like, you know, like is there like a for is there some sort
of fortress arc happening or something? I don't know, dude.
You know, I get if people want to keep to themselves, even if
I've got disagreements with the way that they're doing stuff,
if they want to just do their stream and what? Fine. I don't,
you know, I'm not looking to break into your fortress and come
and you in the middle of the night. But if you've got like a
disagreement that you're talking about against someone else publicly
for a long time, why not have a combo in the top right corner?
You know,
dual loyalty again. Hitting us with the dual loyalty over here.
This is uh Wait, I actually don't know which way this is going
now. See, this is what I'm talking about. Aiden's always getting
100% wrong. 0% on the true false test. He's actually got like
the 150 IQ. He's just doing memes. And Shimu, I've seen Shimu
talk a bit about this too. And it's like it's all over like Ethan
Klein and it's stupid. It's just stupid.
you know.
Wait, is he talking is he referencing the thread here?
No, he's referencing a tweet Shimu replied to Alex Gagmo's tweet
with. Dude, I uh I don't know about you, I like Shimu's video
kind of the Techone video that they're criticizing the Techone
video at all. It's like, dude, that's a that's kind of like a
shot video. Like, there's really not a lot to criticize there.
It's so funny. Like any other time they'd be saying it's like
commentary video of the year or some, but they literally can't
do it, man. It's so funny.
Like it it's actually so clean.
I don't know. It's clean absolutely just tech tone. He's just
like total.
Yeah. And even the sound points like basically unassailable like
Did Hassan watch it? Taking issue with it.
How did Hassan not watch it? I feel like Hassan should watch
it. Ben's watched it. Did she based? Yeah.
Oh, same thing.
Uh, dude, he's not me.
Shimu said my two favorite exports from China. Um, Genchin Impact
and Fentinel. She wasn't happy with that joke. She didn't like
that.
Super funny though. Um, can you answer the question you've already
answered on Jtocks and Razy's stream? I'm watching Sunday's vid
is too hard. What are these
Oh, here we go. Okay. Bit of a shame that commentary is going
into a fortress arc. Not everyone likes Quean, but I think his
takes are
But sorry, I think his takes and opinions are all grounded fairly
well, even if you disagree. Different opinions are good. I don't
think everyone needs to be best friends to exist in the same
space. Why can't you just name names? Sorry, bro. We're we're
talking about differing opinions on a particular on particular
aspects of the Ethan Klein drama and people acting like this
is a life ordeath situation. Like it's all good, guys. We're
all adults. Unless I'm missing some context. Someone can let
me know that. This is the tweet people are mad about. No, that's
what Chad was referring to. No other mad about that tweet. Oh,
the comments on this. Count muted this person. Who else could
you be talking about besides Nick and Willie? Drawing so many
lines in the sand leaves a mess beach messy. Just think he's
boring. I don't know. Queebman sounds like I'm Alex and I don't
think commentary should ever enter the Brit era again. Queman's
great honestly good to have someone.
What's that? Playground anglophobia.
It happens. Bring their bag covering this drama and someone else
is only wanting to have the conversation about why Klein is the
boogeyman and somehow sweeps harder for Hassan than even Hassan
orbiters. I get it. No idea why I'm following you. Are you someone's
mod? Jesus. Oh, it's this guy. Oh, I've seen this guy in chat.
I didn't realize this was the guy. This is the guy in the VC
the other night, too. It's the same guy. The avatar guy.
I'm sorry. You really got to change. Don't Don't roll a chibi
avatar in this community, bro. What are you doing? Show avatar
guy. Yeah. Don't Don't roll with chibi. Dude, chibi equals not
great. Okay, dude. I'm ready to go do some other [__]
Okay, we got to get through this ch thing. I got to get through
it. Got to finish it. Like I dude, I am not looking to start
nuking relationships because of the Ethan Klein Assan drama.
I've got my issues and I've, you know, somewhat stated what my
concerns were the other day and that's enough of me. I'm not
looking to get into some massive beef about, oh, you're not doing
this right or that right. It's just, you know, obviously some
disagreements, some issues that can be hashed out if wanted,
you know, and that's it. Yes, exactly. Shelby the the re, you
know, EHD, well, Destiny is a is a kind of, you know, I I kind
of regret including Destiny cuz it's coming part of it now, but
really it's Ethan Asan or, you know, I guess Idubbbz you could
include as well, but the problem is is that it's all got suck
everything gets sucked up into it. You know, every piece of drama
now is somehow tangentially related to that and it just is it's
just boring. No, it's it's I don't know if that's actually true.
I feel like that's actually not true. And I do think like none
of the com nobody wants to go and cover other stuff because there's
just so much money there. Like the the reason it seems like stuff's
getting sucked up into that is because if you can get the tiniest
wrinkle of anything that's Ethan Hassan stuff, you can just make
a money covering it and blowing it up, right? I like I actually
think there's other interesting stuff going on all over the place.
People just don't really want to cover it. Well, there is if
you're pro Ethan. They're actually I I've done nothing but lose
off of supporting the song side. But sure, if you even call it
supporting the song side, maybe there would be one if I actually
supported the song side, but I don't I don't I just say that
the Ethan side's wrong. Yeah. Oh, don't worry. I know there's
a lot of people who don't want to watch any of my if I'm ever
covering anything regarding this stuff, uh I people are like
quite annoyed most of the time. Yeah. Luckily, eventually we
just get on to other things. But like we've had some I don't
know the Tech All the Tech stuff was good. Did Chud watch the
Techone video? The Shimu? He must have watched the Shimu video,
right? Yeah, he did. Yeah. Yeah, he watched the stream video.
Yeah, Tech comment reaction.
Commented on He's been commenting on my now, too. He's all over
the place. He's a loser, man. He's a total loser.
That's very funny. That's like somebody I Oh, man. You could
push that guy off. You never should have made it as far as he
did. Yeah, he I don't know how he did. Is it just that he was
in Gacha and everybody else was like and doing there needed to
be there? Asmin Gold was Asmin Gold for MMO and now he's As for
politics and they needed to be an asthma gold for Gacha and Tech
was willing to base himself in that way. I don't even know. Yeah,
maybe. I you would assume so based on like how he is now, but
like I actually can't say. I don't I I thought about going back
and watching a bunch of stuff. I know he's literally the last
streamer on the Dan Selman anti- Twitch
Uh, sure he is. But anyway, we uh we to talk about all the time
for me at least. And if people want to talk about it, fine. You
know, I would just hope that they're able to bring some nuance
to the table and do it in a way that, you know, gives gives fair
credence or credit to each side. But, you know, at the end of
the day, I'm not I'm not interested in endlessly talking about
it. You know, it's like And I get it. I get that you like it
and it's fun for you and you want to see everyone talk about
the same thing. I get it. I understand. But it's like people
I watch the Idubbbz coach conversation and it's like I would
happily watch some person on Idubbbz if it was like some video
or something, right? But the problem is that has now been sucked
up that like the ecosystem is at the moment. It's just been sucked
up and has become another piece of this stupid forever war that
Ethan Nano engaged in and have been engaged in for months and
months and months now, you know, and it's just everything links
back to that. And it's just
boring. And if you want to make a ton of money talking about
it, you know, I'm not I'm not don't have a problem with that.
Good luck to you. You know, I'm just personally bored of talking
about it. And uh you know, that's why I'm not really that interested.
Also, dude, Chud is fair. Like that, bro. That's a meme. Does
Tommy understand that Chud is fair is like a joke. Okay, that's
wonderful. That I sometimes allude to after press people. Your
decision to not cover HD is the best thing you've done this year,
keeping me safe. Thank you. Thank you. Yeah, you know, it's uh
I'm doing my best find stuff to talk about.
You know, obviously I you know, I my my take is to try and you
know, give give reasonable assessment to any side in a drama
and not just be completely one-sided and biased, right? And that's
why people then say Chud is fair, but that's how you should be
anyway when you're covering drama. But also, Chud is fair is
a meme rooted in the Tom Foolery stuff when Tom Frery was posting
on Reddit about himself and was saying that, you know, Tom is
fair in the third person. You know, it's not meant to be like
a serious God, a simpler time, a simpler, you know, drama classic.
You had to be that. You really did. You never know the good times
when you're in them until they're gone. Till they're and sitting
in the gutter. It's [__] up statement of of that
is like such a long arc as well. Like from when I first found
those Reddit
also literally like a year and a half, two years. Do you think
we're like so crazy? Do you think we're in that that process
right now? Like maybe we're in that process with uh Hectone or
something? I could see techone.
I don't know.
Yeah. I don't know,
man. Like I'm giving a reasonable take on a drama, particularly
if it's contradictory to what the like common like perception
is out there or something, right? But it is alluding to a meme,
you
know. Um, but yeah, I think that's it really. I think that's
it. Um, was there anything else? Anything else that got mentioned
that I've not spoken about? Bro, he did a stream before this
that I caught a little clip of about your crash out where he
was saying, "Don't cover it then like me." He's just totally
unaware of anything you've done in months. Yeah, dude. Like,
I'm not I don't want to do the Jordan Peterson meme where you've
got to like watch all my streams in order to figure out what
the criticism is of me or something. But anyone that's watched
me knows that I've wrangled with my frustrations with how there's
been an overwhelming presence in the space and I've generally
moved away from covering it, even if it's top content that maybe
I could benefit from. You know, why doesn't Chud ever come on
your stream? Jay Dog. Uh Chud has kids, might have like a partner
or something. He probably spends most of his time not like he
also probably puts 10 hours a day into his streaming stuff, right?
Whether that's like planning stream streaming itself or planning
to do other things for stream, setting up any collabs he's doing,
setting up anything he's doing outside of or what's the other
one. Uh like he does his gaming streams and stuff. He probably
Yeah. And then yes, he he sleeps at like the exact time I stream
at is basically his his worst time. So, uh he still has come
on a couple times. sometimes like I could maybe get him on before
his stream, but I think what his concern would be if he did that
cuz I feel like I know this is my concern. If I join a VC before
I start my stream, I'm not going to plan anything out for my
stream. Like usually when I wake up, it's like, okay, I have
to go and like actually find stuff to cover or else I'm just
not going to have a stream, right? So, and I Yeah. So, I would
imagine it's the same thing for him if I had to guess. So, you
know, like obviously if I was just cons I mean, you know, it's
a balance, right? Obviously, I need to make money to pay my bills,
but you know, I'm fortunate that I don't necessarily have to
cover that all the time, you know, in order to to have a reason
of viewers I can earn an income from, which I'm very appreciative
of, by the way. Thank you for that. So, you know, I don't, you
know, feel the need that I have to cover it because I can talk
about other things people still watch and people still support.
But, um, yeah. Oh, yeah, the Musty thing. What was the Musty
thing about? Yeah, he was talking about how he got a 5k donut
from Musty or something. I I I mean again another thing like
like the idea that people don't want to come on my stream because
I'm a snake or something. That's that's another thing that I'm
hearing about for the first time.
No idea about anything to do I've got no clue about a 5k dono
that Musty gave to Tommy C. That is the first time I was made
aware of that. I'm not familiar with it. Um I struggle to see
how Bro, this guy literally ch switched topics multiple times
like during this and he's still going. If Nicholas had an issue
with you, he would have talked with you. Tommy shouldn't intervene
in this.
I think. Okay. Right. What was it? Your goggling. Let's go balls.
We get it, man. I don't know anything about that
Musty was someone that supported me quite a lot.
Um to the tune of, you know, thousands of dollars. I mean, I
don't like to talk about oilers. It's a bit go, but, you know,
Musty was like a big supporter of me for a while. And as far
as I understand it, he stopped dishing out the the oiling to
to everyone that he was oiling previously. And you know, I I
try not to rely too much on like an oiler because obviously people
come and go and you've got to not be weird about that. But yeah,
Musty obviously hasn't been around for a little while. I think
he gave like a dono and and said, you know, I'm not really doing
oiling anymore and that was that. You know, is probably almost
certainly just like a day trader, right? I'm guessing if he was
any good at if he was like anything other than lucky, he'll probably
be back to giving people money again at some point. Like if I
had to guess a child.
What's that? He claims he fostered a child. That's why he's not
around anymore. Oh, weird.
Um I don't I don't really understand what the like I don't know
I don't know about this 5k dono. I don't really care about the
5k dono one way or another. You know, if you're getting support
for something good for you, I'm not I'm not like I don't really
think anything about it, you know? So I don't understand like
it just feels like this this this bizarre like oh you're concerned
about this. I don't even know. I don't even know about that,
dude. I didn't no idea that happened. So, how can I be like,
know, how can I be like annoyed about something that I I don't
know about or what was it jealous or something? I don't [__]
do. I don't know what his issue was. Perceived issue with this
Musty donor that I didn't know about.
So, yeah. No idea what that was about. Um, Musty is someone that
used to support me a lot and then stopped supporting me for whatever
reason, personal reason, whatever. That's up to him. I don't
really keep track of like I mean obviously you notice if someone
that spends a lot of money on your channel goes but I'm not like
feeling a certain way about it. It's just the way it goes. You
know many people are saying they saw you telling Musty in New
York to lighten the envelope. Now he's going to bring his Irish
crew to put a hit. Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make
money off depressed people? Genuinely glad you moved away from
the HD. It was fun at first but has been looping and looping
outside of the recent coach interview. Stick to stuff you enjoy.
You're great to watch when you're having Thank you for the super
chats. Yeah, that's the other thing as well is that, you know,
if I was if I was still just covering EHV content or whatever,
I just be I just kind of suck. I'll be bored. I'll be bored of
talking about this. So, I just would not be able to bring the
same energy, you know, I think about that random Titan segment
that I did and even though it's not going to get as many views
or whatnot, like that to me is is when my content is at my best.
I'm like just having a laugh about some crazy like that, you
know, or covering a drama I'm actually interested in or something
like that. So, you know,
I don't know. It's uh that's that's about it, right? For the
stuff in the Tommy Cit.
Maybe maybe I'll actually say he's putting a bow on it. I suppose
until he watches the parry video. Really into it and there's
plenty of places to watch it if you are. Um, but yeah. Anyway,
that's the musty thing. Anything else? Was there anything else?
I think that's it. Is it down again? Yes. Unfortunately, Tommy
C's call out for me has had a negative impact on my subs. So,
it looks like some code Tommy C people are not happy with me
subscribing, bro. I don't believe it. Yeah, we're down to 49.
We're down to 49989. Wow. Incredible. About 30 subs. I think
we've lost people happening in like anymore. Tragic. Will I ever
truly reach 50K, dude? Dude, Tomy's whole audience, whole third
of Tommy's audience just left. Oh, hang on. Sorry. Okay, that
was banter, by the way. That was just banter. That was a serious
comment. Okay, it was a serious flight. That was banter. Come
on, let's calm down. I don't get it, dude. Maybe it's just an
American thing. Go over here with banter, you know? Okay, that's
wonderful. But how do I make money after press people? You've
another rant. Well, rather than have another rant. Why don't
we have a conversation? Yeah, save ourselves a lot of time. I'm
not I'm not I'm not doing some sort of queer response response
response thing. I'm not getting into that. I'm not interested.
It's like it's becoming this. What's that meme? Oh, dude. I can't
remember what the name of the people are. The thing is when it's
got like the four videos responding, you know what I mean? You
know what I'm talking about? We like the four the four videos
and they're just doing a response video to each other. The ransas.
Yes. You dude, this is just funny. Sorry. I was looking um just
looking at there's like people like this on all of videos. Um
used to chase you. This actually isn't even true. I'd actually
I actually explicitly ignore Destiny reacting to the case a couple
times and just reacted with my or just did my own coverage. The
one time I did react was when he I mean sometimes I react when
he does the uh conspiracies, but this is just like the same thing
under everything now. Why won't you react to this guy's thing
when he has private knowledge that you don't and you don't have
any actual like any objective basis to retort with? Why won't
you just without the transcript just say that he's wrong or something?
Cuz I'm not a uh yeah I'm not going to go I'm not going to go
fire up his stream and listen to what he says and go he's wrong
when I have literally no basis to do
I have no basis to even comment on his he can just say what he
thinks what stuff was and I have no objective record of anything
to talk about. It's pretty dumb. It's it's just embarrassing
but whatever. Goofy stuff. Goofy stuff. What is it called? I'm
not the car me yet. No, I do want to cover it but um I got some
other stuff I want to get to. Oh, I do actually want to cover
it. Dude, that card that card video is funny as
I watched that I think I watched that in a parking lot. I was
like I had to go home and do a bunch of and I ended up going
to this place like an hour before my appointment because I don't
know. So I sat in the parking lot watch card postings video on
Josh Moon and bronies. Personally I would never shake the hand
of a grown man who watches a ch a child woman child female. What
did he say? Little oh little girls cartoon. Little cartoon the
times is bad. There you
go. Where is it? In the reaction. It's not It's the YouTube responding
to one of those people. Every season of the Geological Podcast
has a falling out to cap it off. First the withune, then DM,
then Rome, then Sunday, now Tommy Cile. Next season you'll have
a fallout with a creator people actually like and could name.
Thank you for 33. Dude, I don't feel like I'm falling out with
anyone, you know? I'm not I'm not falling out with anyone or
anything. I mean, it's true. I haven't spoken to Tommy for like
6 months at this point. Um, so I mean like what what will change?
I'll continue to not talk to Tommy. I mean what? There's nothing
we don't have to speak anymore to be fair. Not I don't think
I've been that angry. I don't think I've been that angry. I You
tell me guys. You tell me. I think I've been pretty calm. All
things considered, my rage is not really not really. How do I
make money after press people? Ch will sit there with a grin
and felt you with his words and then says with just banter. Well,
no. I mean, obviously it is a bit of like a meme, but like you
know, there are things I say not meant to be. Take it super seriously,
right? Like there's obviously an element of seriousness that
I've got points to make, but it's like, you know, I was like
raging at Connor and you know, obviously I thought it was funny
and I did have like, you know, serious disagreement with like
trick stuff, the tricks and street stuff, but it wasn't like
that deep. It wasn't like super deep. I mean, I wasn't genuinely
trying like it, you know. You want me to show him this rile?
Apparently, somebody's you. But the funny thing is, I think we
literally talked about this yesterday, the day before. I can't
remember. He responded to this exact point. I mean, you literally
were beade when you were in a call with Destiny. What? You're
absolutely a snake. Even stayed quiet to get on his kick or keep
show. My gosh, it's so funny. It's so funny that you like literally
literally brought this up yesterday. This exact discussion that
would be like so
to attack someone on personal life allegation type [__]
that isn't fully proven. What you don't have is like the same
point. You don't have an objective record that you can check
any lies against. They can infinitely just pull out facts that
may not even be true to disprove whatever you're saying and you're
just they're just asking for you to completely bomb.
Um look like a be stupid. It's funny that it's like it literally
I answered the comment and then Ri said sort by new and look
at this and he's not referring to this one but this is like the
same literally these two points were part of the same topic.
JCO is not nice to this is not true. I am nice to everyone. Wait
that said I stayed quiet. I literally
explicitly asked Kelly to say you know this guy like hates you
right and it all it all happened and this guy was like yeah fine
bring him on. I I actually told Kelly I I was like just so you
know like if you're worried about getting kicked off of that
show I was like you should understand that Quan does hate death.
See I sufficiently poisoned the well. Okay. I was like I obviously
want Queen to be on the show but you should understand that like
if you're putting your reputation out at all. He does hate him.
He might say some
Yeah. Quum is a contrarian uninsufferable one. Oh this one is
the one that Ra wanted me to show you. Queen is a contrarian,
an insufferable one. Wait, pull down the replies. Let's see the
replies. Come on. Is standard for I'm going to challenge my opinions
from the commentary community. Nope. Literally, definitionally.
Oh, this is the one that he wanted me to read. Let's see. Here
we go. I think there are very obvious examples of this. Just
as you all don't think the sword was chosen specifically because
it almost looked like a Nazi symbol, I don't think Queenman believes
it was chosen entirely by accident. That's too silly. No one
thinks that the sword was chosen by accident. It's very easy
to explain. That is the cosplay prop sword. That is the biggest
that Hassan uses in pretty much any instance where they're posing
with a sword. They don't use the real swords cuz they're heavy
and more difficult to pose with. And that's the coolest prop
cosplay sword that he has cuz it's the Ichigo sword. Not just
is it sword. It looks badass regardless where got swer or not.
It's a long black sword. That's why they use that sword. That's
why songs used that sword in every instance that he's posed with
a
That was chosen as an edgy joke. Look, I'm a Nazi Ethan to further
convey the anti-semitic hallucinations he is being accused of
in the rest of the video. We've been publicly siding with just
called Doro audience captured. Sitting sitting the stating citing
the Oh, citing the very obvious conclusion Jesus that everyone
else has made him by definition a contrarian.
What?
Okay. No, it doesn't. What? No. Contr That's not what that means.
I don't know what he's he's literally arguing that um he said
that everyone else disagree with the majority. Wait, no. Yeah,
exactly. But they're saying that it's a it's contrarian because
I say Nick Durio is audience captured for coming to a conclusion
that everyone else came to. No, it's kind of reliant on at least
everyone else within your sphere coming to that conclusion for
you to be audience captured. Those two things have to be happening
at the same time, right? That they like follow. Yeah. You can't
have a situation where someone is audience captured but not agreeing
with everyone around them. So that's like so doesn't make any
what you even Yeah. Is just saying if you disagree with my group,
you're a contrarian. It's like okay.
I was going to say like infamous infamous contrarian capernicus.
That's the guy who said that the the earth was round and and
not the center of the universe, right? That's the guy who like
got chastised by the church, right?
Am I getting that right? Hold on. He's saying Hassan can't name
three characters from Bleach. What part of my point relied on
Hassan being able to know anything about Bleach?
What for? Which part of my argument relied on that?
Yeah, he's one of those. Got it. Good. I didn't even listen to
what you just said, but obviously goofy sword and yes, I agree
with you in the audience captured. Like, yes. Also, sorry, the
the idea that they're audience captured um or sorry, the idea
that you're being like this would require you're being contrarian.
They're not to be like a side who said that this is clearly like
just a like fluke or whatever or not even a fluke. Sorry. This
is clearly like not done to make an anti-semitic dog whistle,
but there is a whole side. There's like literally half the people
involved in this drama think that.
The fiends need more feeding from time to time. This is a problem.
What is
Oh, kick is so stupid sometimes. Hold on. Just crashed. We love
kick. We love Eddie. We We won't I mean, I do actually literally
love kick and Eddie. So, I'm just saying it gets annoying when
it the pages crash cuz I'm on a VPN. It's kind of annoying. Want
to say it? They don't actually want to come. Well, sorry. That's
that question answers itself. He doesn't think it's the way that
it works. He just knows that he can say whatever he he wants
to this gaggle of clapping seals, these clapping seals, and they
will go they totally made up about you. Yeah, they're totally
making up about
you. Tell me to talk about my mom.
That is what they're like. That is actually what DJ like. I was
about done. That's actually what DJs are like. That's like a
pitch perfect impression right there. Unironically, tell me about
hey, [__] my mom again.
Oh god.
Uh, I did
man, where is the clip? He did. You did you look at any of the
Pixie filings or whatever? Hold on, let me pull this up.
Uh, court listener. I'm so close to being done and I keep pulling
things up.
Um, just I was I was like included in this lawsuit because I
said I would uh testify whatever if they need if they need like
a statement or something from me. Where's John Doe? I don't remember
if these are the ones
or these must be the
ones. Okay, so basically this was a thing that got brought up
in the Pixie case, right? and they they like marked out her avatar,
not my avatar, my name.
Yeah, I saw this when this popped up on stream, I like laughed
super hard about it and Destiny just included it in his like
latest uh response to something going like this guy clearly isn't
worried for his safety at all. And it's like, well, no,
like he makes the dumbest arguments and it's just like I don't
understand. Yeah, I don't care that this identity is revealed
because I'm literally asking if I can announce publicly the thing
that I then went and announced
publicly. Like it is obvious that people will know who I am and
that I'm not concerned about my pseudonym being revealed or attached
to the case in any way. But that's very different from the like
real life identity, right? Where this guy has literally tried
to find my real life identity, tried to publish it and has threatened
by has literally said you guys should go and try to kill this
guy. like it's I don't know. It's pretty obvious that there's
like a massive difference between these things, but it's like
nobody nobody even points out that that's clearly what's happening
here. Uh I basically told Pixie exactly how they should formulate
this. Hopefully they don't have any issues, but it's like I literally
like imagine I was an author writing um you know, it's just a
pen name, right? It's a pen name and I don't care if the pen
name is like attached to the negative opinions of Destiny or
being harassed by Destiny. But obviously my real name, my real
identity, that could have implications far beyond the internet.
That would be really really annoying, right? That like, oh, if
the pen name had to go, but I will use my real name and real
everything for the court case if that's what you guys need. I
just want it to be under protective order because then I then
Destiny doesn't receive it.
That seems totally reasonable, but they're just not smart enough
to understand that. I don't know. Dying is super annoying. It's
not just dying. It's like how do I know that there won't be some
DGER who like learns that name and like signs me up for can like
look look me up in databases or something and just with me, right?
Like there's a whole bunch of things that could be done and like
years after I'm possibly like done streaming. I don't want to
deal with any of that. That
Anyway, where the were we? This is done. Uh this is done. There
was one other thing I was pulling up. Oh, this comment. No, I
don't think Queen actually believes the sword was chosen uh and
angled at the camera on accident. But to argue the point citing,
well, everyone is calling this a Nazi dog whistle. It's a bleach
sword, but nobody he doesn't even that's that's just not a Nazi
dog whistle. Those people are literally the people who complain
and hate Nazi dog whistles. Also, a swastika is not a dog whistle.
Everybody hears a swastika. It couldn't even possibly be a couldn't
even possibly be a dog whistle. Nobody's saying that. Makes it
so clear to me what this is. No, people are calling it What was
he saying? Nobody is calling it a do Nazi dog whistle.
crazy. Anyway, I'm going to look at the comments here real quick.
This guy ever
Nope. Very curious how this guy goes and posts this and then
never responds to any of the comments. Anyway, be my epic own
bro. No, I don't. Sorry, man. I'm not gonna I clearly We're We're
done with the stream here, guys. All right, we'll be back tomorrow.
I'll be back tomorrow. Uh W stream. I think I'm taking T I'm
probably off on Tuesday. I think I got to be out on Tuesday.
So, we'll see what we're doing after that. I'm not totally sure,
guys. Okay. But probably like Tuesday. probably Tuesday we're
off and then we get Sunday,
Monday, Wednesday.
We'll see. We'll see what's going on. You watching more gape
in the oil call? Uh, no. I don't know. We're not doing oil call
tonight. Too late. Too late. Too late. Too late. Have a good
night, guys. W30.